AFTERNOON EVERYONE AND WELCOME
TO OUR SECOND ASSEMBLY SELECT
COMMITTEE ON INCARCERATED WOMEN
HEARING. DUE TO THE CONTINUED
STAY AT HOME ORDER WE ARE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCING
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL BUILDING
SO WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING IN
PERSON. WE REQUIRE WEARING
MASKS AND MAINTAINING PHYSICAL
DISTANCE BY ALL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TESTIFYING WEATHER HERE
IN THE ROOM OR AT A VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITE. IF YOU DO
NOT HAVE A MASK ONE CAN BE
PROVIDED FOR YOU. WE HAVE A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. WHEN WE REACH THE
PUBLIC COMMENT PORTION OF THE
AGENDA I WOULD ASK THAT ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HERE IN
THE ROOM PLEASE APPROACH THE
MIKE ONE PERSON AT A TIME. AND
PLEASE MAINTAIN SOCIAL
DISTANCING AS YOU MOVE AROUND
THE ROOM I WOULD ASK THAT THE
PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE
YOU CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM
ONCE YOU ARE DONE PROVIDING
YOUR COMMENTS OR RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL INCLUDING
LIMITING ELEVATOR USED TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. IN ADDITIN%
TO BEING ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM
INSIDE THE HEARING ROOM WE HAVE
SOME PANELISTS AND OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC MAKING
USE OF. REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATIONS LOCATED ON THE CAPITOL
GROUNDS AND IN A FEW OTHER
LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THOSE WITNESSES WILL APPEAR ON
THE SCREEN SO MEMBERS CAN WATCH
THEIR TESTIMONY LIVE. AND THEN
ASK THEM QUESTIONS SO FOR DIAL
IN WITNESSES WE WILL ALSO BE
USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. THE
CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING.
IS. 888-858-8575. EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHT FIVE EIGHT EIGHT
FIVE SEVEN FIVE AND THE ACCESS
IS FIVE FIVE SEVEN ONE. YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY WEBSITE AND ON YOUR
TELEVISION SCREEN THE OPERATOR
ON THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN QUEUE TO PROVIDE YOUR
PUBLIC COMMENT IF YOU ARE
CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE. THIS INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCAST AND YOUR DEVICES TO
REDUCE THE SOUND DISTORTION. WE
MAY NEED TO LIMIT HOW LONG EACH
PERSON HAS TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT AS WE WILL NEED TO EXIT
THIS HEARING ROOM IN TIME FOR
CLEANING PRIOR TO THE NEXT
INFORMATIONAL HEARING THIS
AFTERNOON. THIS HEARING IS
SCHEDULED TO GO UNTIL TWO PM AT
WHICH POINT WE WILL HAVE TO
CONCLUDE TO ALLOW FOR PROPER
DISINFECTANT AND CLEANING. SO
THANK YOU IN ADVANCE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. WE HAD ORIGINALLY
PLANNED TO HOST THE SELECT
COMMITTEE HEARING INSIDE ONE OF
THE WOMEN'S PRISONS. SO THAT WE
COULD TALK WITH WOMEN INSIDE AS
WELL AS THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
RELEASED AND ARE ADVOCATING ON
BEHALF OF INCARCERATED WOMEN.
WE ALSO HAD PLANNED A FINANCIAL
LITERACY WORKSHOP WITH SOME
CREDIT UNION PARTNERS. AS WE
LEARNED THAT FINANCIAL
LITERACY. WAS A TOPIC OF GREAT
INTEREST TO WOMEN WHO ARE
INCARCERATED AND ARE GETTING
READY FOR RELEASE. THOSE PLANS
OBVIOUSLY WERE STALLED AS A
RESULT OF THE PANDEMIC BUT
NEVER THE LESS THIS COMMITTEE
HAS PERSISTED BECAUSE THE
ISSUES AND FOCUS OF THIS
COMMITTEE SEEM MORE IMPORTANT
NOW THAN EVER BEFORE. THIS IS
THE SECOND HEARING OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE THE FIRST WAS
HELD IN LOS ANGELES AND FOCUSED
ON THE MANY WAYS WOMEN FIND
THEMSELVES INTRODUCED TO THE
CARCERAL SYSTEM. WE HAD WOMEN
OF DIFFERENT RACES ETHNICITIES
AND GENDER IDENTIFIED
ORIENTATION. DISCUSS THEIR
JOURNEY INTO PRISON FOR MANY IT
SEEMED TO BE A COMBUSTIBLE
COCKTAIL OF POVERTY. PREVIOUS
ABUSE SUBSTANCE ADDICTION
UNSTABLE HOUSING AND
EMPLOYMENT. AND VOLATILE POWER
BASED RELATIONSHIPS WITH A
PARTNER THAT LANDED THEM IN THE
SYSTEM. WE ALSO HEARD FROM
PRACTITIONERS FROM THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AND PROGRAMS
LIKE THE OFFICE OF DIVERSION
REHABILITATION WHO SHARED THEIR
ROLE IN THE CHARGING SENTENCING
AND REHABILITATION OF WOMEN.
NEEDLESS TO SAY THERE WERE SOME
DIVERGENCES WHICH I CONSIDER TO
BE OPPORTUNITIES. FOR FUTURE
POLICY M. SYSTEM CULTURE CHANGE.
THIS SELECT COMMITTEE HEARING
WILL FOCUS ON WHAT HAPPENS TO
WOMEN INSIDE OF PRISON THERE
WILL BE A PARTICULAR EMPHASIS
ON HEALTH AND SAFETY AND HOW
THE CALIFORNIA PRISON SYSTEM
HAS RESPONDED TO THE UNIQUE
NEEDS OF INCARCERATED WOMEN
DURING THIS PANDEMIC. BUT I
WANT TO REITERATE THAT THE
TESTIMONY MAY AND CAN ALSO
COVER ISSUES OF TREATMENT ABOVE
AND BEYOND THE PANDEMIC. IT IS
FAIR TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WOMEN
ARE ABUSED AND ASSAULTED IN
PRISON AND THAT THE SAME SEXUAL
POWER DYNAMICS. THAT OCCUR
OUTSIDE OF THE CARCERAL SYSTEM
ON ALSO HAPPEN WITHIN AN- IN
ORDER TO FORMULATE SOLUTIONS WE
NEED INPUT NOT ONLY FROM OUR
LEGISLATORS. BUT ALSO FROM OUR
SYSTEM AFFECTED. SISTERS I AM
THANKFUL TO HAVE THIS OF MY
FELLOW COME MEMBER AND SUCH
SOLUTIONS. AND SO THEY DO ALL I
GO SEE ANY HERE PHYSICALLY I
WANNA OPEN THE FLOOR FOR ANY
MEMBERS TO PROVIDE WELCOME
REMARKS ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER-
HAD. CONFIRM THAT HE WOULD BE
IN ATTENDANCE AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WALDRON- HAD CONFIRMED
SHE WOULD BE IN ATTENDANCE
THROUGH THE VIDEO CONFERENCING
SO I WANT TO. SEE IF EITHER OF
THEM. I MEAN I DON'T SEE MISTER
COOPER SO HOPEFULLY HE'S NOT
GHOST BUT- IF MISS WALDRON IS
ON THE LINE I'D LIKE TO OPEN IT
UP TO HER AND ANY OTHER MEMBERS.
HELLO MADAM FAIR CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES AND WE CAN SEE YOU GO.
I'M HERE I'M SO EXCITED TO BE
HERE TODAY AND- VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THIS
SELECTIVITY THAT YOU PUT
TOGETHER- I DO KNOW THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS HAS
MADE- INCARCERATED WOMEN A
PRIORITY AS PART OF THE
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS THAT WE
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT. AND IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY AND CALIFORNIA-
WOMEN IN CALIFORNIA JAILS HAS
INCREASED 210010% AND THE
NUMBER OF WOMEN IN STATE
PRISONS HAS INCREASED A
WHOPPING. FOUR HUNDRED AND 33%
HUESO FAIR. IN CARTS REMAINS
WRITING WITH WHY. WOMEN
CONSTITUTE A RISING NUMBER
BEHIND BARS AND THAT IS A VERY
BIG CONCERN AND MAKE THE WORK
OF THIS COMMITTEE THAT MUCH
MORE IMPORTANT AS WE TACKLE THE
ISSUES. THAT ARE FACING- WHAT
WHAT'S CAUSING THIS TO BRING
MORE WOMEN INTO REHABILITATION
AND RESTORATION RATHER THAN
INTO INCARCERATION AND MORE
TRAUMA TO THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES. YOU KNOW SO MANY OF
US SOUNDS OF THE BATTLE CRY
BACK IN THE BEGINNING IN MARCH
WHEN THE PANDEMIC- FIRST MADE
ITS APPEARANCE. AND YOU KNOW WE
LOOK AT THAT NEED FOR EMERGENCY
PLANNING IN OUR PRISONS AND ARE
JAIL- THE NEED FOR ADEQUATE
RESOURCES AND PROTECTION BOTH
FOR THOSE PEOPLE INCARCERATED
AS WELL AS THE GUARDS AND THE
STAFF. BUT UNFORTUNATELY A LOT
OF THAT FELL ON DEAF EARS AND
THEN WE HAVE TO SIT BY AND
WATCH AS- SO YOU ARE BEHIND
BARS GOT IT ALL. SORRY THIS AND
MANY WITHOUT ANY ABILITY TO
SPEAK WITH THEIR LOVED ONES OR
HAVE LOVED ONES NEAR DURING
THOSE TIMES OF TOM. SO I KNOW
WILL HEAR. EMOTIONAL TESTIMONY
TODAY. AND IT'S VERY THAT THEY
COME THE WHITE. AND I JUST
WANTED YOU AGAIN MADAM CHAIR
FOR PUTTING THIS COMMITTEE
TOGETHER. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WALDRON FOR THOSE
PROVOCATIVE AND THOUGHTFUL
WORDS. AND WE HAVE BEEN JOINED
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER WHO I
WOULD LIKE TO INVITE TO MAKE
ANY INTRODUCTORY REMARKS. THANK
YOU. ARCHER ONE I'M EXCITED TO
BE HERE AND LOOKING FOR
DISCUSSION A LOT GOING ON INMY
FORMER LIFE I WAS THE CAPTAIN
WITH THE SECOND COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT. NO THE
JOKE COMMANDER FOR TWO YEARS-
THE JUDGE OF THE COURT OF THE
HOUSE TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED PRE
TRIAL INMATES IN THERE SO AND A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WOMEN IN
INCARCERATION. AND THE ONE
THING THAT'S IMPORTANT TO ME
RIGHT NOW THE- RECIDIVISM RATE
FOR CDC IS OVER 50% MAYBE EVEN
SIXTY PERCENT. AND THAT'S A BIG
ISSUE WEREN'T ENOUGH WITH THAT
AND NO ONE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION OR ANYWHERE. IN
GOVERNMENT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
GOVERNMENT TO TABLE TO SERVE AS
A RATE IS FOR COUNTY JAILS. IN
MOST FOLKS ARE BEING SENT TO
COUNTY JAILS THERE IS THE RATE
MAY BE UP 270% NOBODY ELSE SO
WE'VE GOT TO HAVE. BETTER
PROGRAMS MORE EFFECTIVE
PROGRAMS OUT THERE- TO MAKE
SURE THESE WOMEN GET THE
TREATMENT THEY NEED. AND A LOT
OF THE MORE VICTIMS I MEAN
VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND OTHER ABUSES AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. AND RIGHT NOW THE
LAWS IN CALIFORNIA DON'T
REALLY. IMPACT THE PERPETRATORS
THE MEN THAT COMMIT THESE TYPE
OF CRIMES SO WE GOTTA DO A
BETTER JOB ALL THE WAY AROUND
TO LOOKING FORWARD TO.
DISCUSSION FOR MY COLLEAGUES IN
HEARING FROM- SOME THE
ADVOCATES AND VICTIMS INVOLVED
SO THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. THANK
YOU MISTER COOPER ALSO FOR
THOSE THOUGHTFUL AND
PROVOCATIVE WORDS I'D LIKE TO
JUST- ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THIS IS
A- AT BIPARTISAN ATTENDANCE AND
SO IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
WE HAVE FOLKS FROM. NORTH TO
SOUTH AND- FROM ALL PARTS OF
THE SPECTRUM THAT ARE INVESTED
IN THIS ISSUE. SO NOW I'D LIKE
TO PASS IT OVER TO ME COME.
MODA WHOSE POLICY THE DIRECTOR
OF THE YOUNG WOMAN FREEDOMS.
FOR A BRIEF AND- TO HERE. WILL
BE SET. THE TAPE FOR US. THANK
YOU AND WELCOME THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS TO MICAH MOTA AND THE
STATEWIDE POLICY DIRECTOR AT
THE YOUNG WOMEN'S FREEDOM
CENTER AND A CO FOUNDING MEMBER
OF THE SYSTEM FOR YEARS FREEDOM
COALITION. END OF FORMERLY
INCARCERATED WOMAN WHO SPENT
SEVEN YEARS INSIDE CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTIONS. THE YOUNG WOMAN'S
FREEDOM CENTER HAS BEEN WORKING
IN CALIFORNIA FOR OVER TWENTY
SEVEN YEARS TO LIFT UP THE
VOICES AND EXPERIENCES OF
DIRECTLY IMPACTED PEOPLE. THE
SISTER WARRIORS FREEDOM
COALITION IS A NETWORK OF OVER
SEVEN HUNDRED CURRENTLY AND
FORMERLY INCARCERATED AND
DIRECTLY IMPACTED. WOMEN TRANS
AND GENDER EXPANSIVE FOLKS
WORKING TO SHIFT POWER IN
CALIFORNIA. WE COLLECTIVELY
DRAFTED A FREEDOM CHARTER WHICH
WE USE AS A NORTH STAR FOR OUR
MOVEMENT. ONE OF THOSE CHARTER
STATES WE HAVE THE RIGHT TO BE
CONSULTED WHEN INSTITUTIONS
WANT TO CREATE REVISED AND
ELIMINATE POLICIES LEGISLATION
RULES OR LAWS. THAT WILL IMPACT
THE WAY WE EXPERIENCE SYSTEMS.
THIS HEARING HONORS THAT CHOI
BY BRINGING ALL TO. WE BELIEVE
THAT THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN MOST
IMPACTED BY INCARCERATION AND
SYSTEMS THEIR FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES ARE THE EXPERTS IN
THEIR OWN LIVES AND BEST
POSITION TO COLLECTIVELY
IDENTIFY ALTERNATIVES TO
INCARCERATION CRIMINALIZATION
AND FAMILY SEPARATION. WE ALSO
FAITHFULLY SHOW UP FOR EACH
OTHER AND FOR THE ONES THAT WE
HAVE LEFT BEHIND IN PRISON.
CALIFORNIA STATE PRISONS HAVE
BEEN UNDER FEDERAL RECEIVERSHIP
FOR OVER TWO DECADES. FOR
FAILING TO PROVIDE ADEQUATE
HEALTH CARE. IN THE WOMEN'S
PRISONS WE HAVE SEEN THIS PLAY
OUT IN SPECIFIC WAYS. INCLUDING
FORCED STERILIZATIONS. SEVERE
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH CARE
NEGLECT INCLUDING TRANS WOMEN
AND MEN. GENDER BASED AND
SEXUAL VIOLENCE AND A SUICIDE
EPIDEMIC. THE CONDITIONS THAT
HAVE CREATED THIS CRISIS OUR
LONG STANDING AND WITH
UNPRECEDENTED LEVELS AND RANKS
OF INCARCERATION AND POLICIES
THAT HAVE IMPACTED THE MOST
STRUCTURALLY MARGINALIZED
POPULATIONS. ON OCTOBER TWENTY
FOURTH THE AMERICAN PUBLIC
HEALTH ASSOCIATION RELEASED A
STATEMENT DECLARING THAT
PRISONS ARE PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS. THE TOP THREE APHA
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE ALIGNED
WORK WITH WHAT ADVOCATES HAVE
BEEN CALLING FOR. TO URGENTLY
REDUCE THE INCARCERATED
POPULATION TODAY BEST FROM
PERSONAL SYSTEMS AND INVEST IN
HOUSING AND EMPLOYMENT. AND
SUMMIT COULD TO COMMIT TO NON
PERSONAL MEASURES FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY SAFETY AND WELL
BEING. AS COVERT NINETEEN
SWEEPS THROUGH THE PRISONS WE
NEED TO FOCUS ON THE CAR
SERRATION. IT IS A CRITICAL
TIME TO READ OR PAROLE WITH
SERIOUS AND CHRONIC ILLNESSES.
THE RELEASE RATE FOR PEOPLE
THAT CDCR AND THE RECEIVER HAVE
ASSESSED AS ELIGIBLE FOR
RELEASE BASED ON HIGH RISK
MEDICAL STATUS. IS LESS THAN 1%
WE BELIEVE THAT LARGE SCALE
RELEASES ARE SAFE AND
RESPONSIBLE OPTION. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR FOR CONVENING THIS
HERE TODAY THANK YOU SEE YOU
SEE ARE FOR BEING HERE AND FOR
THE FORMERLY INCARCERATED
PEOPLE COMING TO JOIN THIS
PANEL AND LIFT UP MY SISTERS ON
SET WE THINK YOU. THANK YOU AND
MICAH AS ALWAYS. WE ARE PROUD
TO HAVE YOU AS AN ALLY. OF THIS
COMMITTEE. SO I WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE OUR FIRST PANEL WHICH
CONSISTS OF PROFESSIONALS WITH
IN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
THEY WILL SHARE THEIR
PERSPECTIVE ABOUT HOW RESPONSES
TO HEALTH AND SAFETY HAZARDS
CAN BE IMPROVED BOTH THOSE
CAUSED BY THE COBIT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC AND THOSE EXACERBATED
BY THE COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
THEY WILL SHARE THE CHANGES
THEY FEEL ARE NECESSARY TO
ENSURE THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
INCARCERATED WOMEN THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. DR HEIDI BAUER IS
THE DEPUTY MEDICAL EXECUTIVE
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH CDCR DR BAUER
WILL BE PROVIDING AN OVERVIEW.
OF CDC OURS HEALTH AND PAPA
SAFETY POLICIES IN LIGHT OF THE
PANDEMIC SHE IS HERE WITH US IN
PERSON THANK YOU. WE ARE ALSO
DELIGHTED TO WELCOME COLBY
LANDS IN LEGAL ADVOCATE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
WOMEN PRISONERS AND AMENA
ELSTER ALSO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION OF WOMEN PRISONERS.
IN ADDITION I MEAN A IS THE
FOUNDER OF THE ADVOCACY GROUP
UNAPOLOGETICALLY HERS WHICH
SEEKS TO SUPPORT THE
EMPOWERMENT AND ELEVATE THE
VOICES OF THOSE DIRECTLY
IMPACTED BY THE CARCERAL SYSTEM
BOTH COLBY ENEMY NO WILL BE
JOINING US. VIA PHONE SO
PANELISTS PLEASE BE AWARE THAT
YOU WILL HAVE FIVE MINUTES TO
SPEAK. WE WILL BE GOING IN THE
BORDER BY WHICH I'VE INTRODUCED
YOU AND AFTERWARDS WE WILL OPEN
UP TIME FOR QUESTIONS FROM THE
MEMBERS. DR BAUER I'D LIKE TO
INVITE YOU. FORWARD TO SPEAK
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
HEIDI POWER I SERVICE THE
DEPUTY MEDICAL EXECUTIVE FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH FOR CDCR AND FOR
THE CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. I'M HERE
TO PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF OUR
EFFORTS TO RESPOND TO THE
CALVET NINETEEN PANDEMIC WHICH
REMAINS THE HIGHEST HEALTH AND
SAFETY PRIORITY. FOR OUR
DEPARTMENT. SINCE EARLY MARCH.
TWENTY TWENTY THE DEPARTMENT
HAS IMPLEMENTED A NUMBER OF
SYSTEM WIDE STRATEGIES AND
PRACTICES TO PREVENT CONTAIN
THE MONITOR AND COMMUNICATE THE
IMPACTS OF PROBATE NINETEEN ON
OUR RESIDENT POPULATION AND
STUFF. WE CONTINUOUSLY UPDATE
THESE STRATEGIES AND PRACTICES
AS NEW INFORMATION ABOUT THE
DISEASE AND ITS MANAGEMENT ARE
PROMULGATED BY FEDERAL AND
STATE PUBLIC HEALTH
AUTHORITIES. BASED ON LESSONS
LEARNED FROM SAN QUENTIN AND
OTHER OUTBREAKS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM PUBLIC
HEALTH EXPERTS. THESE
STRATEGIES AND PRACTICES ARE
FUNDAMENTALLY MEANT TO MINIMIZE
THE RISK OF BRINGING THE VIRUS
INTO THE FACILITIES. INTERRUPT
THE SPREAD OF PROBATE NINETEEN.
PROVIDE TIMELY AND EXTENSIVE
TESTING TO PATIENTS AND STUFF.
APPROPRIATELY HOUSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO REQUIRE ISOLATION OR
QUARANTINE. MONITOR PATIENTS
WHO ARE ILL AND. PROVIDE HIGH
QUALITY MEDICAL CARE. AND PRINT
PATIENTS WHO ARE VULNERABLE TO
EXPERIENCING SERIOUS
COMPLICATIONS FROM THIS DISEASE.
IN ORDER TO MITIGATE EXPOSURE
AND SPREAD TEST ISOLATED
QUARANTINE AND PROTECT THE MOST
VULNERABLE AND PROVIDE CLINICAL
CARE TO SYMPTOMATIC PATIENTS HE
STRATEGIES AND PRACTICES WE
HAVE IMPLEMENTED INCLUDE BUT
ARE NOT LIMITED TO. THE
EXPEDITED RELEASE OF NEARLY TEN
THOUSAND VIGILS INCLUDING OVER
NINE HUNDRED WOMEN. STOP TO
VISITATION IN MARCH OF TWENTY
TWENTY. IMPLEMENTED SYMPTOM AND
TEMPERATURE SCREENING AND
PHYSICAL DISTANCING.
DISTRIBUTED PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT AND CLOCK FACE
COVERINGS FOR STAFF AND
RESIDENTS ON AN ONGOING BASIS.
IMPLEMENTED DISINFECTION
PRACTICES AND PROVIDED HAND
SANITIZERS. STOPPED IN TAKE
FROM JAILS WHICH HAS RECENTLY
BEEN SLOWLY RESUMED UNDER VERY
TIGHT RESTRICTIONS. THE
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED THE
MOVEMENTS WITHIN THE PRISON AND
ACROSS PRESENTS WITH VERY
STRINGENT TESTING AND
QUARANTINE PRACTICES WHEN
MOVEMENT IS NECESSARY. WE'VE
DEPOPULATED DORMS AND OPEN SO
FRONT HOUSING. WE'VE EXPANDED
TESTING CAPACITY AND REDUCE
TURNAROUND TIMES TO RECEIVE
MOST PROBATE NINETEEN TEST
RESULTS WITHIN TWO DAYS FOR
BOTH RESIDENTS AND STAFF.
IMPLEMENTED RIGOROUS CONTACT
INVESTIGATIONS FOR THOSE
EXPOSED AND CLOSE CLINICAL
MONITORING OF THOSE IN
QUARANTINE AND ISOLATION.
IDENTIFIED ADDITIONAL ISOLATION
AND QUARANTINE SPACE INCLUDING
THE USE OF TENSE AND RE
PURPOSED AREAS OF THE PRISONS.
PROVIDING ONGOING COMMUNICATION
TO STAFF AND RESIDENTS THROUGH
A NUMBER OF MECHANISMS AND
FORUMS. ADDING ONGOING
EXTENSIVE TRAINING TO CLINICAL
STAFF TO ENSURE THAT THEY
REMAIN UP TO DATE. WE'VE
DEVELOPED SEVERAL ELECTRONIC
TOOLS TO TRACK TESTING AND
RELEASE INFORMATION AND MONITOR
ASPECTS OF PATIENT CARE. AND WE
ARE CONTINUALLY UPDATING OUR
ONLINE GUIDANCE THAT FEATURES
INFORMATION ON VARIOUS TOPICS
TO ASSIST WITH THE MANAGEMENT
OF PROBATE NINETEEN OUTBREAKS
AND PATIENCE WITH PROBATE
NINETEEN. WITH REGARD TO WOMEN
WE HAVE HAD THREE HUNDRED
SEVENTY ONE CASES APPROPRIATE
NINETEEN AMONG WOMEN INCLUDING
ONE PREGNANT WOMAN WHO WAS A
SYMPTOMATIC. THIRTEEN PATIENTS
WERE HOSPITALIZED AND THERE WAS
ONE DEATH. COMPARED TO MEN IN
OUR PRISON SYSTEM FEMALE
INFECTION RATE IS ABOUT 30%
LOWER AND HOSPITALIZATION AND
DEATH RATES. PER POPULATION ARE
ABOUT HALF THE RATES FOR MALES.
THERE'S BEEN A SIGNIFICANT
DECREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
POSITIVE TESTS THAT WE'VE HAD
DESPITE VERY AGGRESSIVE TESTING
STRATEGIES. THE CURRENT AND
FUTURE CHALLENGES AND
OPPORTUNITIES WE ARE FOCUSED ON
RIGHT NOW INCLUDE PREPARING FOR
FLU SEASON. AND WRAPPING UP
EDUCATING RESIDENTS AND STAFF
ABOUT THE CRITICAL IMPORTANCE
OF BEING VACCINATED FOR
INFLUENZA OFFERING VACCINATION
TO ALL RESIDENTS. IDENTIFYING
PATIENTS WHO HAVE BEEN
PREVIOUSLY INFECTED WITH
PREVENT WHO ARE POSITIVE. WHO
ARE PAST THEIR NINETY DAYS. M.
MAY TEST AGAIN SO FAR WE ARE
WORKING. WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
FIVE LAB AND WE HAVE NOT I'D
ANY PERSONS WHO ARE RE INFECTED
WITH THIS VIRUS BUT WE ARE
MONITORING VERY CLOSELY.
IDENTIFYING IN CARING FOR
PATIENTS WHO MAY HAVE LONG TERM
SICK QUALIFY OR COMPLICATIONS
FROM THEIR COVERT INFECTION
THAT GO ON FOR WEEKS OR MONTHS.
DESPITE THE REDUCTION IN
POPULATION CENSUS OVER TE LAST
FEW MONTHS CDCR REMAINS ONE OF
THE LARGEST CONGREGATE SETTINGS
IN CALIFORNIA. SO WE HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO FIND WAYS TO
PROTECT THE MOST VULNERABLE
PATIENTS FROM GETTING INFECTED.
INCLUDING ALLOWING THEM TO MOVE
OUT OF DORMS AND OPEN CELL DOOR
SETTINGS. SHE CAN CONSIDERATION
FOR RELEASE OF PATIENTS WHO ARE
AT HIGHER RISK FOR PROBATE
NINETEEN RELATED COMPLICATIONS
WHO ARE LIVING IN DORM SETTINGS
SHOULD CONTINUE. WE ARE
PARTICIPATING IN PLANNING
EFFORTS WITH THE CENTERS FOR
DISEASE CONTROL AND PREVENTION
AND CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH TO PREPARE FOR
PREVENT NINETEEN VACCINE WHEN
IT BECOMES AVAILABLE. WE ARE
COLLABORATING WITH ACADEMIC
PARTNERS AND PUBLIC HEALTH
EXPERTS TO UNDERSTAND FACTORS
THAT WE CAN ALTER OR STEPS THAT
WE CAN TAKE TO PREVENT AND
MITIGATE INFECTION WITH FROM
PROBATE NINETEEN. WE ARE
EXPANDING EMPLOYEE HEALTH
SERVICES INCLUDING FREQUENT
TESTING AND RIGOROUS CONTACT
INVESTIGATIONS TO MITIGATE THE
SPREAD TO OTHER STOP AND
RESIDENTS. WE'RE CAREFULLY
PLANNING AND IMPLEMENTING A
PHASED IN APPROACH TO SAFELY RE
OPEN PROGRAMS AND VISITING.
THIS CONCLUDES MY OPENING
REMARKS I LOOK FORWARD TO
QUESTIONS AND THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SHARE OTHER WORK WE'VE BEEN
DOING. AND WE CONTINUE TO DO TO
IMPROVE THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF OUR RESIDENTS INCLUDING
WOMEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. YOU DR BAUER I'M
SURE THAT SOME OF OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WILL HAVE QUESTIONS FOR
YOU- LATER ON. I MODERATOR I'D
LIKE YOU TO PLEASE OPEN THE
LINE FOR COLBY LANDS WHO IS OUR
NEXT PANELIST. IN COLD AIRLINE
OF OPEN. HI I'M HERE. THANK YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THE
HEARING TODAY- I APOLOGIZE I
WILL BE READING QUICKLY BECAUSE
I JUST WANT TO HELP LAST TIME-
I'M ADVOCATE THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR WOMEN PRISONERS
IN THE TRANSGENDER ADVOCACY
GROUP I'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
INCARCERATED PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA'S WOMEN'S PRISONS
FOR SIXTEEN YEARS. A. P. HAS
BEEN DOING THIS WORK FOR TWENTY
FIVE CALIFORNIA'S PRISON SYSTEM
ITSELF IS A HEALTH AND SAFETY
HAZARD AND HUMAN RIGHTS CRISIS
PRISON BUT A GLOBAL PANDEMIC
TOGETHER HAVE CREATED A PUBLIC
HEALTH DISASTER THAT HAS
ALREADY CLAIMED THE LIVES OF
EIGHTY PEOPLE WE CONTINUE TO
LOSE PEOPLE BECAUSE THE
TEACHERS NEGLIGENCE TO PREVENT
THE SPREAD OF COVERAGE AT ALL
THE ACTIONS THEY TAKE IN THE
CREATED OUTBREAKS OF THE MOST
RECENT DATA 84% OF PEOPLE HAVE
DIED FROM KOGAN PRISONS
CLASSIFIED AS HIGH RISK
MEDICAL. THE AVERAGE PERCENTAGE
WAS SIXTY THREE MORE TAN 75%
MORE PEOPLE LIVING WITH
DISABILITIES OVER 70% OR PEOPLE
OF COLOR IN 89% WERE CONSIDERED
LOW RISK RIGHT PCR ONE OF THE
PEOPLE WHO DIED WAS MADONNA
WATSON BUT DONNA A BLACK WOMAN
IN HER FIFTIES HAD RECENTLY
SURVIVED CANCER AND WAS
MEDICALLY HIGH RISK AT PFW SHE
DIED AS A RESULT OF THE
PERSONNEL CAN BREAK AT W.
BEATING HER LOVING FAMILY AND
MANY DEAR FRIENDS IN PRISON
GRIEVING HER LOSS. HER DEATH
COULD HAVE BEEN PREVENTED THE
OPERATOR LET MADONNA'S DEATH
WAS LIKELY SPREAD BY CONTINUED
STAFF MOVEMENT BETWEEN T. I. W.
IN THE CALIFORNIA INSTITUTION
FOR MEN- SEE I AM WHICH AT THE
TIME WITH THE PERSON WITH THE
MOST SEVERE OUTBREAK IN THE
STATE INTEL RECENTLY CITY
CIRCLING BUT NO SUCH STEP MOVE
THAT WAS TAKING PLACE WELL THEY
SUPPRESS THIS INFORMATION FOR
MONTHS INCARCERATED PEOPLE KEPT
REPORTING THE FACT ADVOCATES
AND JOURNALISTS. THEY LET US
KNOW AT EVERY STEP HOW TO WAS
IN A DEADLY OUTBREAK AND THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. TO NEARLY
NOTHING TO RESPOND. SHE SURE
HAS A LONG HISTORY OF LAW. TO
THE CALL. TO BE. A LINE. UP
NEXT. IN A BECAUSE THEY- GET
AWAY WITH IT BECAUSE OUR STATE.
DOESN'T APPEAR. JOB PERSONAL.
THERE'S ALMOST NO OVERSIGHT.
KNOWS BODY WITH A-
INVESTIGATIVE. BECAUSE ONE
FOUR. SUCH TAX. CAN TO FUNDS.
AND INTO. PUBLIC AND- OVERSIGHT
DOES A GOOD IS LARGELY SUPPORT.
AT THE FIRST OUTBREAK TO CALL
THAT THE I. W. CARTERET OF
PEOPLE WHO TESTED POSITIVE FOR
MOVED INTO HORRID QUARANTINE
CONDITIONS. CONDITIONS THAT
INCLUDED HEALTHY CELLS NOW
WATER SEVERELY INADEQUATE
MEDICAL CARE. MULTI FOOD
ISOLATION AND NO MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. PEOPLE STARTED TO
ATTEMPT. GOOD EXPERIENCING COBA
CONTROLS OR REFUSED EMERGENCY
MEDICAL RESPONSE. PEOPLE IN THE
UNIT WOULD SCREAM INTO A PRISON
GUARD COULD NO LONGER IGNORE
THEIR CALLS FOR HELP FOR
OTHERS. THIS IS WHAT QUOTE
MEDICAL CARE IN CALIFORNIA
PRISONS LOOKS LIKE UNDER COOKED
IT. NOW INCARCERATED PEOPLE IN
WOMEN'S PRISONS AND BEYOND HERE
REPORTING SYMPTOMS BECAUSE OF
THE NEGLECT AND ABUSE OF
QUARANTINE. THIS IS A
REASONABLE RESPONSE BUT YET
ANOTHER ELEMENT OF THE PUBLIC
HEALTH NIGHTMARE THAT CONTINUE
TO CREATE. WHEN WE EXPOSE THESE
CONDITION POW'S RESPONSE SO
THEY HAD NO PROBLEMS IN
QUARANTINE AS EVIDENCED BY THE
FACT THAT. THEY RECEIVE.
FRIEDMAN SAYS. THIS WAS IRONIC
SINCE ONE OF OUR CHIEF
COMPLAINTS WITH THE CURSOR TO
PEOPLE. IN THE UNITED REPORTED
THEY WERE DENIED ACCESS TO THE
GRIEVANCE PROCESS. UP TO A
MONTH. THIS IS WHAT. HAPPENS IN
THE POLICE POLICE THEMSELVES.
ONE REASON I JUST ORDERS FROM.
THE OFFICE OF THE INSPECTOR TO
RELEASED A REPORT TO WEEK FOUND
THAT THE- ARE. ON A- TO BASIC.
PART OF. AND MESSAGE. INCREASE
THE RISK OF SPREADING. THEIR IT
ON THE CAR. AND HEALTH CARE SO
HELPING TO EVEN THE BASIC.
BECAUSE SUCH AS WEARING FACE
COULD THE GREATEST. BETTER
PRODUCT ABOUT OF. SOLUTION
FEATURES THEY REVIEW TO CALL OF.
AND THERE'S NO. BODY THAT
AFFECT FORTY THEM TO COME. WITH
THEIR OWN PAUL. IN SHORT THE-
I. G. THIRTY CAN. WHAT
INFORMING. PEOPLE FAMILY
MEMBERS OTHER ADVOCATES HAVE
BEEN REPEATEDLY STATING SINCE
MARCH. TEACHER WILL TELL TO
CONTROL THIS OF THE VIRUS AND
THAT'S A FIVE. THANKS FOR THE
CALL TO THING IS. IMPRISONED
CONTINUES OUR LOOK AT TO PAY.
UP PREVENTION THE SAFE. AND
ETHICAL. AT LARGE SCALE. THIS
ISN'T NEW INFORMATION. OTHER
HEALTH ACT HAVE URGED RECOMMEND
RELEASES. MARCH DIFFICULT TO
SAY FIVE LARGE RELIEF THE ONLY
WAY TO ACCOMPLISH THAT. IF
YOU'RE STATE THAT HAVE RELEASED
PEOPLE BUT LET'S LOOK AT THOSE
NUMBER. AT THE MAKE AMENDS.
AFTER PUBLICLY AND- A HIGH.
MEDICAL EXPEDITED BELIEVED.
UNTIL FEATURE HAS REALLY ****
1% PEOPLE THAT. ELIGIBLE FOR
HIGHER IT'S NOT. THAT'S LESS
THAN FIFTY P. OUT OF THE- OUT
EIGHT HUNDRED AVERAGE
IDENTIFIED. NOW THEY BY THE
THOUSAND YOU. PEOPLE PETER HAS
REALLY PEOPLE INTO. THAT ARE
POLITICALLY. FOR THEM BUT-
PEOPLE AT GREATER RISK. IT IS
IN PART DUE TO THE REFUSAL TO
PRIORITIZE PEOPLE SENT TO LIFE
AND LIFE WITHOUT PAROLE.
DESPITE THE DATA SUPPORTING
THESE RELEASES. AND I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT YEAH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COOPER THAT THE REST OF
AMERICA VERY DIFFERENT BECAUSE
POPULATION. EIGHT THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED NOT TO THE NUMBER IT'S
ABOUT LIFE AND DEATH FOR ACTUAL
PEOPLE. AND GIVE ME. ARE. AT
SIXTY EIGHT IN THIS OF BROUGH
EIGHT TWO YEARS OLD LOVE OTHER
THAN THE END OF THE- CAR EACH
THANK YOU MOTHER. FOR AND I.
HIGH RISK. I THINK OF RICKY
PLEASE GO WHO STEP FIVE A
TRENCH. MAN AT THE C. W. AT.
YOU HIGH RISK AND A WILL TO.
CRUTCHES THIRTY TWO YEARS
PROFILE. TWENTY IS AN EXTRA TO
COVER. BY QUARANTINE WHAT
PEOPLE DO COLLEGE. I'M THINKING
ABOUT MY HUNDRED HIS EIGHTY.
WITH THE OLDEST ONE THAT. UP
THE SHE HAS NOT SPOKEN. THAT
MAKE CREDIBLY PARTICLES THE
DEBT THE- OF CO. INCLUDE CO.
AND I'M THINKING OF I MEAN I
RUSSELL SEVENTY. DOWN FORTY
YEAR. SHE SUFFERS FROM ALL.
THAT TO THE BLOCK. ALLOW HER TO
TAKE ON THE FUTURE AT A TIME
WITH THE AT THE WALKER. THE
CONTINUED ACROSS. OF EACH THESE
CAN MEMBERS TENS OF. MORE NOT A
PUBLIC SAFETY. IT'S AN AND.
POINT PUBLIC. PROJECT IT ONTO.
PUBLIC NEGLECT IN A- I THINK.
EXPENSIVE AND THE HUMOR COST
AND TIED IN OUTSIDE OF BRITAIN
ARE DEVASTATING. FINALLY I URGE
PLEDGES. IN THIS CAN. TOOK OPEN
MY OF COMMUNICATION WITH.
PEOPLE WANT COVETED. I STRONGLY
SUGGEST THAT COMMITTEE RICH. TO
THE- TO HOLD HEARINGS NO WOMAN
COULD TOOK ME FOR GET DIRECT.
FROM ACROSS REDDIT PEOPLE.
ABOUT THE CONDITIONS THEY ARE
STRUGGLING TO SURVIVE. THAT
HASN'T HAPPENED SINCE THE
NINETEEN. EIGHTIES HERE AND
ULTIMATELY GOVERNOR SOME HAVE
DEMONSTRATED THEIR UNWILLING TO
PAY FOR THIS CRISIS WITH REASON
AND POLITICAL STRENGTH. AND
LARGELY IGNORED RESEARCH AND
GUIDANCE FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
EXPERTS. HUMANIZED AND
DISREGARDED INCARCERATED UPON
THEN CRUSH IT PEOPLE THEIR
FAMILIES AND OUR COMMUNITIES.
HAVE BEEN SWAYED BY POWERFUL
POLITICAL INTEREST GROUPS OVER
SCIENCE ETHICS AN ACTUAL PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY. OPERATE
LOOKING TO CYCLE THROUGH THE
CURTAINS. THE TIME TO ACT IS
NOW TO PREVENT FUTURE LOSS OF
LIFE. FOR PUBLIC HEALTH PUBLIC
SAFETY AND RESPECT FOR HUMAN
LIFE NOTHING ENACT A LARGE
SCALE POLICE. NOW IT'S. THE
ONLY WAY TO SAVE LIVES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU COLBY'S. YOU
TEST. MODER PLEASE OPEN AND I
JUST WANT TO REITERATE TO COLBY
TO PLEASE STAY ON THE LINE IN
CASE THERE ARE QUESTIONS THAT
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE OF YOU
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINE
FOR OUR FINAL PANELIST. AMINAH
ELSTER. I MEAN I YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU I'M GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND
THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME TO
TESTIFY BEFORE YOU TODAY MY
NAME IS AMENA EL THEIR CAMPAIGN
POLICY COORDINATOR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA POLITICAL PRISONERS
DOWNTURN ALLEGEDLY HER. I'M
ALSO FORMALLY INCORRECT HAD
PROVIDED LIKE DEVELOPING PRISON
FOR BUT THE VALLEY WHEN
FACILITY THREE PANDEMIC TODAY
I'M SPEAKING BEHALF OF THE ALL
TIME RECORD THING CAL WOMEN'S
PRESIDENT. EARLY NDEPENDENT
EIGHT A MOTHER HOUSING WITHIN
THE CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S FACILITY
WROTE STATED I QUOTE THE
PANDEMIC IS TAKING A TOLL ON MY
MENTAL STATE. IT'S SO HARD TO
QUESTION BECAUSE SOME PEOPLE
DON'T THINK THE VIRUS IS REAL
WHAT AM I SUPPOSED TO DO WITH
PEOPLE INCLUDING STAFF KNOW
WHERE THEIR MATH AND OFFICERS
DON'T BELIEVE THEY CAN GET IT
IN QUOTE. I COULDN'T ANSWER HER
QUESTION HER QUESTION BECAUSE I
KNOW FIRST HAND THAT THE
STRUCTURAL DYNAMICS WITHIN
PRISON ALL THE DIFFERENT BILL
VALENTINE COUNTED TODAY. AND
HOW DID MOTHER UNIT TO PROTECT
HERSELF COULD DETERMINE HER
FUTURE ACCESS THE FREEDOM
OUTSIDE OF PRISON NO ONE SHOULD
BE FORCED TO MAKE A CHOICE ON
WHAT MORE IMPORTANT THEIR
FREEDOM. FOR THEIR HEALTH.
ANYTHING ARE HAPPY FAILED TO
ADD. SAY. COOL EXPERT THE ORDER
TO EFFECTIVELY PHYSICALLY
DISTANT. WE ARE ISSUE THE
THEORIES OF NPP RECTUS IN
GUIDANCE THAT HAS PROVEN
DEADLY. BENCHMARKS WE HAVE TO
BE CALLED EMAIL THE LETTER
INDIVIDUALS WITH THE CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S FACILITY.
BACK TO THEIR COLLECTIVE
FEELINGS OF BEING LEFT TO DIE.
AND THAT THEIR LIVES ARE NOT
SAFE. AFTER CALL THE INCIDENT
FOR THE PRESIDENT MANY
INDIVIDUALS REPORT THE CORN
FEED ANY UNIT REGARDING OF THE
DUNGEON. I HELPING YOU LOCATE
ON THE PRISON RECEPTION YOU ARE
THAT HAVE BEEN CONVERTED INTO A
HORRIFYING QUARANTINE UNIT. FOR
THE PURPOSE OF ISOLATION.
IMAGINE THE FEAR ANXIETY
CONFUSION AND DISREGARD PEOPLE
EXPERIENCE. WHEN INDIVIDUAL
REPORT TO QUARANTINE TOGETHER
DESPITE THE RESULT OF ANY CALL
BECAUSE- THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE
MAKE A QUARANTINE FOR A WEEK
NOW REPORTED THAT CORRECTIONAL
STAFF FREQUENTLY SAYS THERE'S-
THEIR FAILED WITH NO REGARD FOR
THANK YOU DIRECT IT. AND THAT
INDIVIDUAL HAD NO OTHER OPTION
IF YOU LIVE BENEFIT BECAUSE.
THE CLEAN AIR ACT THE CLEAN. B.
B. W. L. ONE OF THE WAY LARGEST
LIMITS FOR. HOUSES THE MAJORITY
OF PEOPLE DON'T. BAY FAIL. THAT
LEFT EIGHT PEOPLE. FILLED WHERE
AGAIN LOS DIFFERENT THE ISN'T.
AMERICAN THE PANIC AND CORKERY
MAN WOMEN FRANCE. ARE EXPOSED
TIME AND IF IT WITH IT. THERE
WOULD BE OCTOBER TWENTY FOUR
MEMO TRANS. ADMITS THE DVR
STRUGGLING TO PROTECT FACE IN
AND DON'T HOW THE HOLD IT BUT-
BECAUSE ONLY HIRE. TO OUR
PATIENTS. OTHER PEOPLE WHO HAVE
DIED LOOK 480% WERE LIVING IN
THESE HIGH WITH CAN. TRANSFERS
ARE NOT THE ANSWER THEY ARE A
CALL THIS THE- W. F. IT'S NOT
MENTIONED IN THIS REPORT. ADULT
PRIORITY IS A- GIVEN THAT THIS.
NUMBER OF FIFTY W. F. HOUSING
INDOOR BASIC. BUSINESS BY NOT
IN USE. ELEVEN LOOK THE MAN IN.
AYE TO RELIEVE IT FOCUSING ON
THE WHO ARE MEDICALLY HIGH RISK.
AND ALTHOUGH BONTA. IN THE WHEN
YOU PRISON AS WELL AS FOR WOMEN
IN THE MAN'S MUST BE PRIOR. A
REPORT BY THE ALL OF THE
GENERAL X. CDC ARE FACTORED
THEIR FAILURE TO FOLLOW.
DEPARTMENT FAITH. A PHYSICAL
DAY. REQUIRED IN. AND IF YOU GO
BUT THEY PRODUCTS THE BANK.
PRISON INCLUDED BTC ARE. AS
WELL. IT WOULD BE A MISTAKE THE
BELIEVE THAT THE DVR COULD. THE
DID EXACTLY NON. PRACTICES
ATTITUDE THIS BIG THAT THOSE
HELP WITH THE CAL WOMEN'S
PRISONS HAVE. AND INVOLVED
ABOUT THE START DEFENDING. ONE
ORGAN IF YOU W. F. BERMAN
LICENSE THANK AND I QUOTE A
STAFF MEMBER EXTRA CONCERN WITH
CAUGHT. THE VIRUS FROM. HOWEVER
WE CANNOT CAPITAL ON THE FRONT
BODY FOR. BACK THIS FOR THE BY
EVEN FEW THE GIVES BIRTH. THAT
WE ARE NOW BACK GUYS THAT THE
GOOD GUY DO NOT CALL PART OF.
BBVA'S BPR NOT BEEN EFFECTIVE
PUT BEEN THE SPREAD OF THE
NIGHT. NO MATTER HOW CAN. THEY
COREY BE IN QUOTE. CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES STAFF HEALTHCARE
BACK IN THE COMMUNITY AS A
WHOLE. THE ONLY WAY TO DO THIS
IS BY EXPANDING SYSTEMS ARE
REALLY FOR INDIVIDUALS IN FIVE
THIRTY NEXT WEEK THEN IT. DID
YOU KNOW THAT 90% OF PEOPLE W.
LFE CALIFORNIA. WRITTEN WORK IS
THAT THEY'RE IN A BETTER. AND
THAT THEY ARE NOT MAIN ACTORS
IN THE CRIED OR REPORT TO BE
PRINTED WHEN THEIR VIEWS ARE
COMMITTED A MURDER. MANY OF THE
SURVIVORS ARE MEDICALLY HIGH
RISK RECALL BIT ELDERLY.
ANOTHER ORGANIZER INSIDE OF PTW
AFTER A LOT BATES AND I QUOTE
I'M A HYBRID MEDICAL I HAVEN'T
OUT OF THE NEW DISEASE AND I
THINK. YOU KNOW THE PRESIDENT I
ALSO HAVE SEVERAL OTHER CHRONIC
CONDITIONS. MEDICAL RECENTLY
GAVE ME AN ADVANCE DIRECTIVE
FOR HEALTH CARE. POINT SEVENTY
FOUR TWENTY ONE LIVING WILL
FILL OUT TO GET TO MY DOCTOR. I
AM ONLY THIRTY FIVE YEARS OLD I
WAS NOT GIVEN A DEATH SENTENCE
YEAH I FEEL THE PLACES TRYING
TO GET IN ONE. CLOUT THE
MAJORITY OF PEOPLE THINK THAT
THE L. LOBBY CALIFORNIA WITH
ITS PRESENT APRICOT. AND HAD NO
RECORD BY TO BE TO FIT DIE IN
PRISON. CDCR IS NOT NOT NEARLY
ENOUGH TO PROTECT THOSE
INCARCERATED. AND WE ARE THE
DEPARTMENT IN THE STATE TO DO
MORE BACK FORTY TO. THE RELEASE
IT BURKE OWNER VOEPEL.
INCLUDING L. WALKED IN THE
ELEVENTH. ONE THANK YOU THINK
WE'D THE FACT THAT AND
EXPANDING EFFECT BUT- RELIEF
PROGRAM TO INCLUDE OTHER
THIRTEEN EXTREME BUSINESSES. IN
ORDER TO PROTECT LIFE INDEED
THE PANDEMIC. THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO BE. THANK YOU I
MEAN I FOR YOUR TEST OF. SO NOW
I'D LIKE TO OPEN UP THE FLOOR
TO ANY QUESTIONS THAT ARE COME
MEMBERS MAY HAVE FOR OUR- I
DON'T IF ASSEMBLY WALTER IS
STILL PARTICIPATE THROUGH.
TELECOM FOR BUT MOST COOPER IF
YOU HAVE ANY. FOR THE PANEL. NO
I JUST WANT TO THANK THE PANEL
FOR THEIR THEIR WAS VERY EYE
OPENING BUT I'M CURIOUS BECAUSE
YOU'RE THE POPULATION- IT'S
EASY R. IS ALREADY GONE DOWN
BECAUSE OF THE- EVAN
RECEIVERSHIP SAID A HUNDRED
THOUSAND. BUT DO YOU WANT THE
NUMBERS AREN'T COUNTY JAIL
BECAUSE THAT THE KIND YOU ALSO
HAVE TO HAVE CLOSE THAT SAME
POPULATION I BELIEVE FOR THE
KITGUM PRE TRIAL AND YOU KNOW
POST TRIAL FOLKS. AND NO ONE
EVER TALKS ABOUT THAT CENTERS
ABOUT THE OTHER OTHER NUMBERS
FOR THAT BECAUSE- WHEN THE
REASON CCAR'S UNDER
RECEIVERSHIP IS BECAUSE THE
LAWSUITS. AND LOOK HELLO TO GET
THERE AND ACTUALLY BUILD THE
PRISON STOCKTON. WHERE THE
COUNTIES DON'T HAVE THAT SO I'M
JUST CURIOUS ABOUT. YOUR
COMMENT ON THAT BECAUSE IT'S
GOING TO BE THE SAME NUMBERS
ARE LARGER. AND VINCENT BACK TO
BEING HEALTHY COUNTY JAIL TO
FOURTEEN YEARS WE- YOU KNOW
BEFORE IT WAS A YEAR BUT DOUBTS
FOR UP TO FOURTEEN YEARS AND-
YOU DON'T REALLY GET A FEEL
BILL TATIAN IN THE COUNTY JAILS.
WELL I DON'T KNOW IF ANYONE
FROM CDC ARE WANTS TO RESPOND
TO THAT EVENT BECAUSE I IT IS A
COUNTY QUESTION. I DO KNOW THAT
THEY WERE ACTUALLY. I CAN ONLY
SPEAK FOR L. A. COUNTY WORKS
HOLDING FOLKS- DURING THE
INITIAL. PERIOD OF TIME FOR THE
OUTBREAK- INDIAN CDC ARE AS WAS
MENTIONED HAVE STOPPED INTAKE
FROM THE JAILS- AND THEN THEY
ACTUALLY HAD BEGUN TO DO SOME
RELEASES BUT I DON'T I DON'T
HAVE ANY OF THOSE NUMBERS. BUT
WE CAN MAKE A NOTE. THANK YOU I
DON'T KNOW IF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WALDRON. IS STILL WITH US-
HELLO YES I AM HERE YES DO YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR THE
PANELISTS HERE YOU ARE. HI I DO
ACTUALLY- YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT COLD DID WAS VERY
SUCCESSFUL AT DOING WAS
BRINGING TO LIGHT- OF A VAST
NUMBER OF DEFICIENCIES IN OUR
STATE GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS
FROM DDD IS THE ENVY OF ALL OF
THE OTHER THINGS WE SAW BUT
NOWHERE IS THAT MORE STRIKINGLY
EVIDENT. THAT WE HAVE
DEFICIENCIES ARE CORRECTIONAL
FACILITY- WE HEARD THE HORROR
STORIES WE KNEW UNFORTUNATELY
THAT A LOT OF THE THINGS THAT
ENDED UP MANIFESTING WE'RE
GOING TO HAPPEN- DESPITE CALLS
BY SO MANY ADVOCATE ON BEHALF
OF THOSE WHO ARE INCARCERATED
AS WELL AS THOSE WHO WORK IN
THOSE FACILITIES- WE DID HEAR
THE HORROR STORIES WE HEARD
THEM FROM THOSE INSIDE. WE
HEARD THEM FROM FAMILY MEMBERS
WE HEARD IN FROM CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS WHO WERE FORCED TO
BASICALLY SLEEP IN THEIR OWN
CARS OR IN THEIR GARAGES FOR
FEAR OF BRINGING CALLED IT INTO.
THEIR FAMILIES WHEN THEY WENT
HOME. SO WE ALSO KNOW THE FACT
THAT. INCORPORATE PEOPLE. HAVE
A HIGHER RATE OF THAT THE- OR-
HEALTH PROBLEMS MORE SO THAN
THE GENERAL POPULATION. AND WE
ALSO KNOW AND I'VE HAD A
SUCCESSION WITH BOTH THE CDC
ARE- THE CONDITIONS THERE AND
THE FACILITIES MANY OF THEM
ARE. DILAPIDATED AND. JUST THE
CONDITIONS ARE. NOT AT ALL YOU
MAIN CONDITION AND THAT'S
BECAUSE OF THE WAY THE
BUILDINGS ARE ABOUT. THE AGE
AGING OF THE BOTH THE BILITY-
THAT HAVE NOT BEEN UPGRADED I
THOUGHT ALL OF THE THINGS LEAD
TO A VAST AMOUNT OF- INCREASING
OF TRAUMA AND THE HORROR
STORIES THAT WE HEARD I'M GOING
INTO THIS SO MY QUESTION
BASICALLY IS- YOU KNOW.
VISITATION WILL STOP.
APPARENTLY IT'S STILL STOP WHEN
WILL THAT COME BACK AND YOU
KNOW DURING A TIME LIKE THIS
BEING WITH YOUR LOVED ONE
HAVING THAT EVEN CONNECTED TO
SUCH AN IMPORTANT THING
PROBABLY MORE IMPORTANT THAN
ALMOST ANYTHING ELSE. YET THEY
WERE UNABLE TO SUCCESSFULLY DO
A- WHETHER IT'S SOCIAL BENEFITS
OR WHATEVER IT IS THEY WAY
THAT- THOSE INCARCERATED COULD
ACTUALLY SEE THEIR LOVED ONES
AND YOU KNOW I'D LIKE- A COMMON
ADDRESSING THAT AND ALSO WAS
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES STOCK.
AND IF SO WHY. AND HAVE THEY
COME BACK YET. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I THINK DR
pMICROPHONE TO RESPOND TO THOSE
QUESTIONS. YES THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THOSE QUESTIONS- SO
I'LL TRY TO ADDRESS- VISITATION
AS WELL AS THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES VISITATION IS STILL
CLOSED AS OF TODAY WE ARE WE
HAVE BEEN TALKING. EXTENSIVELY
WITH INSTITUTIONS AND
HEADQUARTERS TO TRY TO MAKE
SURE THAT AS WE RE OPEN
VISITING WE DO IT IN A WAY THAT
SAFE. AND WE WANT TO FOLLOW THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UIDANCE ON
LOOKING AT PHASES AND THE
PHASES OF THE COUNTY AND THE
COMMUNITY WHICH IS GOING TO
AFFECT THE RISK. OF STAFF
BECOMING INFECTED AND THE REST
OF THE INSTITUTION. AND ALSO
LOOKING AT THE PHYSICAL LAYOUT
OF THE SPACES THAT INSTITUTIONS
HAVE AVAILABLE FOR VISITING TO
TRY TO IDENTIFY PLACES THAT
MAYBE OUTDOORS OR MUCH MORE
OPEN AND EXPANSIVE WHERE PEOPLE
CAN'T PHYSICALLY DISTANCE- A
LOT OF THE RULES AROUND
VISITING WILL NEED TO BE LOOKED
AT VERY CAREFULLY SUCH AS- NO
EATING NO DRINKING NO SHARING
FOOD- WE MAY NEED TO LIMIT.
PHYSICAL INTERACTIONS SO WE ARE
LOOKING AT ALL OF THE STUFF WE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
GUIDANCE OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH HAS
PROVIDED. FOR RE OPENING LOTS
AND LOTS OF DIFFERENT VENUES
AROUND THE STATE AND WE'RE
USING A LOT OF THE SAME
PRINCIPLES AND APPROACHES TO
DISTANCING AND MASKING AND-
ENVIRONMENTAL DISINFECTION ALL
OF THOSE THINGS WILL BE IN PLAY
AS WE AS WE RE OPEN VISITING.
BUT WE AGREE THAT IT IS A VERY
CRITICAL PRIORITY FOR THE
POPULATION AND FOR THE FAMILIES
TO BE ABLE TO SEE THEIR LOVED
ONES AND BE ABLE TO REMAIN
CONNECTED. IN TERMS OF THE
MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES IN GENERAL- BACK IN
MARCH- WE HAD TO SHUT DOWN A
LOT OF ACTIVITIES. BUT THERE'S
ALWAYS BEEN AN APPRECIATION FOR
WHAT ARE ESSENTIAL ACTIVITIES
AND ESSENTIAL SERVICES AND
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ARE
ESSENTIAL SERVICES. AND SO I
CAN'T SPEAK WITH- DETAIL TO THE
DATA AND ACCESS TO THE SERVICES
BUT- MEDICAL SERVICES HAVE BEEN
OPEN THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
INCLUDING THE SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER PROGRAM TRYING TO
CONTINUE TO SCREEN FOLKS TO GET
FOLKS ENROLLED IN INVOLVED IN
THAT PROGRAM. AND NOW WE'RE AT
A POINT WHERE WE'RE EXPANDING
THAT AS WELL SO THAT WE CAN
ENSURE THAT THE- COGNITIVE
BEHAVIORAL INTERVENTIONS THAT
ARE PART OF THE SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER PROGRAMS. ARE
INTEGRATED WITH THE MEDICAL
ASSISTED TREATMENT SO ALL OF
THIS IS A CHALLENGE FOR THE
COMMUNITY IT'S A CHALLENGE FOR
US BUT WE'RE WORKING REALLY
HARD TO REOPEN THESE PROGRAMS
AND RE ENGAGE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON DO YOU
HAVE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS. ARE
NOT AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
GREAT THANK YOU I HAVE  FEW
THAT THEY WILL BE QUICK- AND SO
HOPING THE RESPONSES. CAN BE
TOO SO THAT WE CAN MOVE TO OUR
SECOND PANEL YOU'D MENTIONED-
FLU VACCINATIONS ARE THOSE
GOING TO BE REQUIRED. OKAY I
WAS HAVING A LITTLE PTSD ABOUT
THE SKI YEAR EXPERIMENT YES
ALRIGHT SO FLU VACCINATION IS
NOT REQUIRED IT'S OFFERED AND
WE HAVE- EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS
AND CAMPAIGNS TO REALLY- TRY TO
GET THE MESSAGE OUT THAT WITH
HOLDEN CIRCULATING AND
INFLUENZA CIRCULATING AT THE
SAME TIME WE NEED TO BE EXTRA
VIGILANT OUR FLU VACCINE UPTAKE
IN OUR POPULATION IS AROUND 50%
HISTORICALLY WE ARE STRIVING
465% IN THE GENERAL POPULATION
AND 75% AND THOSE OVER AGE
SIXTY FIVE. AND SO WE HAVE SOME
GOALS WE'VE ALREADY STARTED
VACCINE PROGRAMS MANY
INSTITUTIONS HAVE ALREADY
STARTED- OFFERING THE VACCINES
EDUCATING THE POPULATION AND
PROMOTING INFLUENZA VACCINE BUT
IT IS NOT MANDATED OKAY AND
THEN TO PIGGY BACK ON ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WALDRON'S QUESTION
AROUND MENTAL HEALTH FOR FOLKS
WHO ARE NOT INCARCERATED WHO
HAVE THE YOU ARE BLESSED ENOUGH
TO WORK IN THEIR HOME AND- GO
PERIODICALLY TO A PARK OR TO
THE GROCERY STORE- BUT ARE AT
HOME WORKING OR YOU KNOW
HELPING THEIR CHILDREN- GAIN
THEIR EDUCATION WE'RE SEEING
UPTICKS IN DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND IN MENTAL HEALTH- SUFFERING
SO I CAN ONLY IMAGINE. THAT IT
WOULD BE EXACERBATED FOR
SOMEONE WHO'S INCARCERATED
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE'VE STOPPED
VISITATION YOU SAID IT ENACTED-
IMPLEMENTED TO SPATIAL
DISTANCING PROTOCOLS AND THEN
REDUCED ACTIVITIES. SO CAN YOU
JUST A LITTLE BIT MORE TO
HOPEFULLY SOME OF THE ENHANCED
MEASURES AROUND MENTAL HEALTH
BECAUSE WE'VE ALSO HEARD ABOUT
AN UP IN- SUICIDE INCIDENTS OR-
X. CENTER US SO I I'M
CONCERNED. THAT WE'RE HOUSING
FOLKS THERE'S A LACK OF
INFORMATION THAT PEOPLE FIND
CREDIBLE COMING TO ALL OF US-
THERE'S A LACK OF ACCESS TO
PHONES I'VE HEARD THAT THE SOME
OF THE MAIL HAS BEEN CURTAILED-
SO WHAT I MEAN CAN YOU SPEAK TO
SORT OF WHAT YOU'RE SEEING AND
MAYBE ELEVATE SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT HAVE COME UP FROM
THE OTHER PANELISTS AROUND. THE
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS IN THEIR
PRISONS. YEAH HEY HERE YOU KNOW
I'VE IT'S BEEN CERTAINLY ON OUR
RADAR SINCE THE BEGINNING AND I
THINK THE CONCERNS ABOUT TO
QUARANTINE AND ISOLATION AND
WHEN THERE ARE EVEN SMALL
OUTBREAKS OFTEN THERE'S
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
IDENTIFIED AS POTENTIAL
CONTACTS. WHO THEN HAVE TO GO
INTO QUARANTINE AND QUARANTINE
IS FOURTEEN DAYS WHICH IS A
VERY LONG TIME TO BE IN
QUARANTINE AND PARTICULARLY IN
SOME OF THE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
WOULD THAT WERE DESCRIBED. SO I
THINK- THERE IF THIS IS BEEN ON
THE RADAR AND UNDERSTOOD THAT
THAT IS A SIGNIFICANT RISK IN
NOT JUST THE PHYSICAL THREAT OF
COVERT NINETEEN BUT ALSO THE
MENTAL HEALTHCHALLENGES THAT
AS YOU SAY ALL OF US ARE. ARE
DEALING WITH BUT ESPECIALLY IN
OUR PRISONS SO WE HAVE- WE HAVE
A MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAM AND I
THINK THEY HAVE BEEN WORKING TO
FIND CREATIVE WAYS TO PROVIDE
THOSE SERVICES IF. PREVIOUSLY
THERE WERE GROUPS OF PEOPLE IF
THEY CAN'T SOCIALLY DISTANCE
PEOPLE THEY CAN PROVIDE ONE ON
ONE COUNSELING- AND SO WE HAVE
TRIED SIMILAR TO THE COMMUNITY
TO ADAPT TO THE WAY THAT
SERVICES ARE PROVIDED. SO THAT
THEY CAN BESAFE FROM AN
INFECTION CONTROL STANDPOINT
THEY CAN BE SAFE FROM MICROBIT
NINETEEN STAFF JOINT I DON'T
HAVE NUMBERS AND DATA MY
FINGERTIPS ON THE MENTAL HEALTH
PROGRAM BUT I WOULD BE HAPPY TO
ELEVATE THESE CONCERNS. AND GET
MORE INFORMATION FOR THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU I'D LAST
FINAL I DID YOU HAVE A
QUESTION. FOR THE DOCTOR AND
THEY SAID THROUGH SHOTS WERE.
OPTIONAL BUT WHAT PERCENTAGE OF
THE- INMATES. GET UP TO GET FLU
SHOTS. DON'T MISS THAT YES SIR
WE HAVE A WE ACTUALLY KEEP
TRACK OF THE OFFERING AND
ACCEPTANCE AND OUR RATE OF.
OFFERING IS ALMOST A 100% 99%
AND SO EVERY SINGLE PATIENT IS
HAS A ONE ON ONE ENCOUNTER WITH
THE PROVIDER EDUCATION ABOUT
THE VACCINE. AND THEY CAN OPT
IN OR OPT OUT TO RECEIVE THE
VACCINE AND HISTORICALLY WE'VE
HAD AROUND 50% ACCEPTANCE RATE.
NOT KNOW ABOUT STAFFERS WHAT'S
WHAT'S THE RATE OF STAFF
GETTING FLU SHOTS AND YOU ARE
THE OFFERED TO STAFF FOR FREE.
YEAH THEY'RE OFFERED FOR FREE
SO WE HAVE AN EMPLOYEE HEALTH
PROGRAM AND THEY COME ON SITE
TO THE INSTITUTIONS AND THEY
HAVE FLU CAMPAIGNS AND OFFER
FLU VACCINE TO THE STAFF- I
DON'T HAVE SPECIFIC NUMBERS A
LOT OF STUFF TO GET THE VACCINE
FROM THEIR PROVIDER OR FROM A
DRUG STORE FROM LOTS OF OTHER.
OTHER PLACES HISTORICALLY ABOUT
25% OF STAFF HAVE OPTED TO
RECEIVE THE VACCINE THROUGH THE
EMPLOYEE HEALTH CENTER. THAT WE
HAVE ON SITE BUT I DON'T HAVE
AN OVERALL PERCENTAGE OF
ACCEPTANCE FOR THE VACCINE
AMONG STAFF OKAY SO THAT'S ALSO
OPTIONAL OKAY SO THIS YEAR IN
THIS ROOM YESTERDAY WITH A
MEETING- WITH PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND WE TALKED ABOUT SOME OF
THE- WITH SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES AND TWENTY PER CENT
PERCENT THE STATE'S DEATH FROM
COVERT CAME FROM SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES. AND YOU
KNOW WE TALKED ABOUT THAT SO IS
THERE ANY PLAN TO MAKE SURE
SINCE THIS IS AN AT RISK GROUP
WHEN THE VACCINE DOES COME OUT
TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE
PRIORITIZE. TO GET THE VACCINE
FOR COLLUDED. PART FOR ONCE A
COVERED VACCINE COMES OUT. YES
YOU'RE ASKING YEAH. I WE WILL
BE WILL BE WORK WITH THIS. AND
WITH THE CDC I BELIEVE THERE'S
A TIERED APPROACH TO
PRIORITIZING CERTAIN
INDIVIDUALS FOR THE PROBATE
VACCINE. AND THAT'LL DEPEND ON
THE TRIALS AND SORT OF WHO
BENEFITS FROM THE VACCINE BUT I
BELIEVE HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS.
ARE IN THAT TOP TIER. AND WE
ARE ADVOCATING STRONGLY THAT
THERE'S CONSIDERATION FOR
CUSTODY OFFICERS AND OTHER
FOLKS WHO WORK IN HIGH RISK
ENVIRONMENTS. BECAUSE NOT ONLY
ARE THEY AT RISK OF. BRINGING
THE VIRUS INTO THE FACILITIES.
BUT THEY ARE AT RISK OF GETTING
INFECTED WHILE AT WORK AND SO
WE ARE ADVOCATING STRONGLY THAT
THEY ARE ALSO PRIORITIZES TOP
TIER AND THEN OF COURSE OUR
PATIENTS OUR RESIDENTS- GIVEN
THEIR UNIQUE RISK. LIVING IN
THIS CONGREGATE SETTINGS. NOT
SURE ABOUT THE FACT THAT A LOT
OF FOLKS GET- DESPONDENT
BECAUSE- OBVIOUSLY THERE'S
RESTRICTIONS FOR THE CODE TO
THE IF THE SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES. THEY'RE NOT ALLOWED
VISITORS EITHER SO THAT'S BEEN
GOING ON FOR. GOD SINCE ITS
INCEPTION SO SEVEN MONTHS WITH
NO VISITORS NOW AND MY MOM'S
ALSO IN A IN A- SNIFF RIGHT
NOW. SO IS THERE ANY. OTHER
GIVING INMATES EXTRA PHONE TIME
OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT ARE
TRYING. TO LEVY IT SOME. OF
THESE THINGS ARE YOU GUYS DOING
THAT. YEAH I'M SURE. MISTER
ABOUT COULD SPEAK TO BUT YOU. I
THERE'S A FREE PHONE TIME
THAT'S BEEN MADE AVAILABLE
ADDITIONAL PHONE TIME THERE'S
BEEN- INTRODUCING TECHNOLOGIES-
THAT THAT. COMMUNICATION
TECHNOLOGIES LIKE WE'RE USING
TODAY- TO CONNECT PEOPLE SO ALL
OF THOSE THINGS HAVE BEEN
INTRODUCED TO THIS GREAT THANK
YOU. YEAH DOES THE CHALLENGE
AND YES. IS THERE ARE A
DIFFICULT BE CUTE. NOUGH YOU
HAVE A I WANTED TO JUMP ON THE
MENTAL HEALTH. ISSUE WHEN WE
YES PLEASE I DO WANTED TO
MENTION THAT I YEAH IN RESPONSE
TO DOCTORS COMMENT THAT I AND I.
THAT MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
WERE SUPPOSED TO CONTINUE-
EMERGENCY SERVICES RIGHT-
THROUGH A CO OP ED BUT WHAT WE
HAVE SEEN HAPPEN IN THE
QUARANTINE UNIT THAT THAT-
PEOPLE HAVE SHOWN CLEAR SIGNS
OF SUICIDALITY- AND BEEN
REFUSED ACCESS TO EVEN BASIC
CONTACT WITH THE MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDER- IN ONE CASE YOU KNOW
SOMEBODY. THOUGHT THAT THEIR
CELL ON FIRE IN AN ATTEMPT TO
COMMIT SUICIDE AFTER SHOWING
CLEAR SIGNS FOR A WEEK- PEOPLE
WERE BEGGING FOR HELP. AND THEN
THERE WAS A LACK OF RESPONSE TO
THAT- INCIDENTS WHILE WHICH
CAUSED ALL SORTS OF PROBLEMS.
AND MORE MENTAL HEALTH. THE
STRESS FOR EVERYBODY IN THE
HORN UNIT RIGHT AND THEN
FINALLY WEEKS AND WEEKS IN.
MENTAL HEALTH DOT COM AND THEY
BROUGHT COLORING BOOKS AND- PUT
TOLD YOU KNOW PUSH PUSH THOSE
SHEEP UNDER PEOPLE'S DOORS AND
THAT WITH THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICE. SO WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT YOU KNOW CRISIS
CONDITIONS ON TOP OF CRISIS
CONDITION. IN THE CONTEXT. OF A
OF THE PRISON SYSTEM AND
SPECIFICALLY C. I. W. IN THIS
CASE. WHERE THERE'S BEEN A
SUICIDE CRISIS- THAT WAS EIGHT
TIMES THE NATIONAL AVERAGE NOT
LONG AGO RIGHT. SO WE ARE
LOOKING AT AN EXTREMELY
DANGEROUS SITUATION- SO I JUST
WANT TO POINT TO THE FACT THAT.
THE SERVICES DID NOT EXIST EVEN
THE EMERGENCY SERVICES THAT
SHOWED UP- AND WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED THAT THAT'S GOING TO
CONTINUE AT THIS- COULD
CONTINUE TO CYCLE THROUGH THE
COULD. THANK YOU FOR THAT COLBY.
YOU SAID INCREASED VISITATIONS
AS I HOPE THAT ALSO ARE PEOPLE
pCOUNCIL TO TALK TO THEIR
COUNCIL. NO OKAY ANOTHER
QUESTION I HAVE COME IN BUT AND
SHARED WAS DENIED ACCESS TO
GRIEVANCE PROCESS SEES I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
SOMEONE CAN SPEAK TO THAT COME
UP FROM ONE OF THE PANELISTS.
HI I'M KIM SIDELINE THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF FACILITY OPERATIONS
FOR- CDCR AND- YEAH THERE'S
BEEN A COUPLE QUESTIONS I CAN
ANSWER ON THE PHONES- THERE'S
BEEN ACTUALLY BEEN AN INCREASE
IN OPPORTUNITIES FOR PHONES.
HOWEVER AND THERE HAS BEEN- AN
pINCREASE IN HOW WE MAINTAIN THE
CLEANLINESS AND SANITATION OF
THE PHONES. SO TYPICALLY PRIOR
TO CO BID WE WOULD HAVE A
FIFTEEN MINUTE PHONE CALLS THEY
WOULD SIGN UP AND THEY WOULD
JUST BE CONTINUING TO
CONTINUING THROUGHOUT THE DAY.
HOWEVER WITH HAVING TO MAINTAIN
SO MUCH SANITATION WE'VE HAD TO
REDUCE THE PHONE CALLS TO ABOUT
A TEN MINUTE PERIOD TO ALLOW
FOR SANITATION AND THEN WITHIN
THE SANITATION THEY HAVE TO
DRIVE. WITH THE AIR FOR FIVE TO
TEN MINUTES IN BETWEEN EACH
VISIT SO THAT WE CAN ENSURE
THAT THERE'S NO CONTINUED COBIT
IN SEPT- THAT WE'RE IT MIGHT
APPEAR THAT THERE'S BEEN A
REDUCE PHONE CALLS THERE
HASN'T. ARE ALSO OUR PROVIDER
DETAIL HAS BEEN PROVIDING TWO
DAYS OF FREE PHONE CALLS EACH
MONTH SINCE THE START OF COBIT.
AND THEN ALSO BACK ON MOTHER'S
DAY WE OFFERED VIDEO GROUNDS
THAT ARE THREE FEMALE
INSTITUTIONS- FOR THE WOMEN AND
WE ARE SO ARE STILL- LOOKING IN
INTO EXPLORING MORE OTHER VIDEO
TYPE- OPPORTUNITIES FOR
VIDEOGRAMS AND COMMUNICATION
AND WE'RE STILL IN THE
EXPLORING STAGE OF THAT THERE
WAS A COMMOTION ABOUT ACCESS TO
COUNSEL THERE'S BEEN NO-
DENIAL. FOR TO ACCESS TO
COUNSEL WE'VE BEEN PROVIDING
PHONE CALLS AND THINGS LIKE
THAT AND ALSO- KIND OF LIKE
WHAT WE'RE DOING NOW SKATE.
MMHM AND THEN YOU HAD ONE OTHER
QUESTION A GRIEVANCE PROCESS
GRIEVANCE PROCESS- SO. I'VE
I'VE ACTUALLY HEARD THAT
MYSELF- I WENT OUT TO ONE OF
OUR FEMALE INSTITUTIONS. TO
LOOK TO SEE IF THEY'RE STILL
EVERYONE STILL HAD ACCESS TO
OUR BOXES AND THEY DID-
REITERATED WITH OUR
INSTITUTIONS THAT EVERYONE HAS
ACCESS TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
FORMS. AND THAT THERE ARE STILL
BEING CHECKED EVERY DAY QUITE
DESIGNATED STAFF THEY'RE LOCKED
AND SECURED- IN THE BOXES ARE
STILL AVAILABLE WITHIN THE
HOUSING UNITS. THANK YOU I'M. I
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME TO OUR SECOND
PANEL- BUT I DO THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO SAY THAT GTL IS
PROHIBITIVELY EXPENSIVE FOR
MANY FAMILIES AND I THINK THIS
WE'VE ENTERED INTO A TIME WHERE
WE SHOULD ACTUALLY BE.
RECONSIDERING OUR PRACTICES
ABOUT NOT ALLOWING FOLKS WERE
INCARCERATED TO HAVE CELL
PHONES- SO. THANK YOU PANELISTS
FOR YOUR TIME AND
PARTICIPATION- I'D LIKE TO NOW
MOVE ON TO OUR SECOND PANEL WHO
WILL BUILD UPON THE POLICIES WE
HEARD ABOUT FROM OUR FIRST
PANEL AND HOPEFULLY PROVIDE.
INSIGHT INTO THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THESE POLICIES WITHIN
FACILITIES. HERE TODAY AT THE
CAPITOL WE HAVE KIMBERLY C.
ABLE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
FACILITY OPERATIONS DIVISION OF
ADULT INSTITUTIONS. IN ADDITION
WE HAVE PATRICIA WRIGHT WHO WAS
RECENTLY RELEASED FROM THE
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE FOR WOMEN
AS WELL AS THE ANA CARE AWAY
RECENTLY RELEASED FROM. THE
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S
FACILITY BOTH OF THOSE WOMEN
WILL BE JOINING VIA REMOTE
TESTIMONY. AS WITH OUR FIRST
PANEL PLEASE BE AWARE THAT YOU
WILL HAVE FIVE MINUTES TO SPEAK
AND WE WILL BE GOING IN THE
ORDER BY WHICH I INTRODUCED
YOU. I WOULD NOW LIKE TO INVITE
KIMBERLY SEPAL TO THE
MICROPHONE FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING
US. AND THANK YOU- GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TALK
TO YOU TODAY ABOUT CDC- IS
WOMEN'S HEALTH AND SAFETY
WITHIN. STATE FACILITIES. SINCE
THE BEGINNING OF COVERT
NINETEEN WE HAVE TAKEN SEVERAL
STEPS TO PROTECT THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF ALL THOSE LIVING AND
WORKING WITHIN OUR
INSTITUTIONS. IN MARCH OF
TWENTY TWENTY CDCR TOOK
IMMEDIATE ACTION TO IMPLEMENT
MANY HEALTH AND SAFETY
PROTOCOLS. AND PROCESSES WITH
THE ASSISTANCE OF OUR
HEALTHCARE PARTNERS. C. C. H.
C. S. WITH GUIDANCE FROM THE
CDC ARE AND CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH. IT
WAS UNDERSTOOD THAT COPA
NINETEEN WOULD EVENTUALLY
RETURN SITUATION SO WE
IMPLEMENTED MANY EXTREME
MEASURES FOR THE PROTECTION OF
EVERYONE. ALL PROGRAMS WERE
SUSPENDED TO INCLUDE VISITING
AND PROGRAMS ALL NONESSENTIAL
STAFF WERE DIRECTED TO TELEWORK
TO REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF STAFF
ENTERING THE INSTITUTIONS.
SCREENING AND TESTING PROTOCOLS
WERE IMPLEMENTED FOR STAFF AND
INMATES. EDUCATION POSTERS
FLIERS ANNOUNCEMENTS TO GET HIT
DETAILING WAYS TO REDUCE AND
PREVENT COVERT NINETEEN WERE
SHARED WITH STAFF AND INMATE
POPULATION. THERE WAS AN
INCREASE IN NURSING ROUNDS FOR
ALL QUARANTINE AND ISOLATED
PATIENTS. PATIENTS RESIDING IN
OPEN DORM AREAS RECORDED IN
PARTS OF NO MORE THAN EIGHT PER
COHORT AND SIX FEET APART FROM
EACH OTHER. SOME WERE MOVED TO
SELL HOUSING WAS SOUL ITSELF
FRONT DOORS. ASIANS WERE
FURTHER ENCOURAGED TO SLEEP IN
OPPOSITE DIRECTIONS HEAD TO TOE
TO FURTHER REDUCE THE SPREAD OF
COVE IN NINETEEN. HAND
SANITIZERS ARE PROVIDED IN ALL
DINING HALLS HOUSING UNITS
OFFICE SPACES IN AREAS OF HIGH
TRAFFIC. WE INCREASE THE
FREQUENCY OF CLEANING IN
TERMINAL CLEANING EFFORTS. IN
HIGH VOLUME AREAS SUCH AS DAY
ROOMS DINING HALL SHOWERS
RESTROOMS AND TELEPHONES. CLOTH
BASED MASK WERE PROVIDED TO ALL
INMATES AND STUFF. IT WAS
ASSIGNED TO AN ISOLATION OR
QUARANTINE HOUSING AREA OR
PROVIDED IN NINETY FIVE FACE
MASKS AS WELL AS OTHER PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT. MOVEMENT
IS FURTHER RESTRICTED TO THOSE
RESIDING IN THE SAME LIVING
SPACE TO FURTHER REDUCE CROSS
CONTAMINATION AND MOVEMENT.
MARKERS ARE PLACED ON THE
GROUND SIX FEET APART WERE
LINES WOULD FORM FOR MEDICATION
DISTRIBUTION CANTEEN LAUNDRY
YOUR DINING HALLS AND OTHER
AREAS OF THE INSTITUTION TO
REMIND EVERYONE. MAINTAIN
SOCIAL DISTANCING. REMINDERS
ARE ANNOUNCED TO BE OUR PUBLIC
ADDRESS SYSTEM EACH DAY ON
SECOND AND THIRD WATCH
REMINDING EVERYONE TO MAINTAIN
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND WEAR.
FACE MASKS AND APPROPRIATE PP.
INSTITUTIONS ACTIVATED THEIR
INCIDENT COMMAND POST WHICH
ALLOWED FOR BETTER COORDINATION
EFFORTS WITH OUR HEALTHCARE
PARTNERS IN TRACKING OF TESTING
SURVEILLANCE HOUSING AND
MOVEMENT OF THIS OF INMATES.
THAT'S REDUCING THE LIKELIHOOD
OF CROSS CONTAMINATION. WARDENS
ARE CONTINUALLY MEETING WITH
THE INMATE ADVISORY GROUPS TO
ENSURE THAT THE MOST UP TO DATE
INFORMATION IS BEING SHARED
BOTH WAYS. WE ACTIVATED
NONTRADITIONAL HOUSING AREAS
SHOULD THE NEED ARISE TO
INCREASE SOCIAL DISTANCING. WE
SUSPENDED INTAKE FROM COUNTY
JAILS FOR A TIME AND RECENTLY
STARTED COUNTY ITAKE WITH
COORDINATION WITH OUR COUNTY
AND HEALTH CARE PARTNERS TO
ENSURE THAT THOSE RECEIVED A
CODE FREE. ALL VEHICLES VANS
BUSES ARE DISINFECTED BETWEEN
EACH TRANSPORT ALL PERSONS AND
VEHICLES ARE REQUIRED TO BE IN
THE N. NINETY FIVE MASKS WITH
APPROPRIATE PP. AND WE FURTHER
REDUCE THE NUMBERS OF THOSE
BEING TRANSPORTED TO CREATE
INCREASED SOCIAL DISTANCING TO
REDUCE ANY TRANSMISSION. FOR
INSTANCE A BUS CAN TYPICALLY
TRANSPORT THIRTY EIGHT PERSONS
HOWEVER THAT NUMBERS CURRENTLY
BEEN REDUCED TO NINETEEN TO
ALLOW FOR SOCIAL DISTANCING.
SINCE MARCH RE RELEASED
APPROXIMATELY NINE TURNED NINE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE FEMALE
OFFENDERS VIA THE NATIONAL
PAROLE OR EXPEDITED PROCESS. IN
AN EFFORT TO ALLOW FOR
INCREASED FAMILY COMMUNICATION
WE'VE INCREASED PHONE CALLS TO
CERTAIN PRIVILEGE GROUPS AND
OUR TELEPHONE CONTRACTOR AS
STATED EARLIER IS PROVIDED
ADDITIONAL TWO DAYS OF FREE
CALLS EACH MONTH. AND AS I SAY
EARLIER ALSO OUR MOTHER'S DAY
WEEK VIDEO WERE ALSO FROM FOR
THE- FOOD SALES HAVE BEEN
PERMITTED ALBEIT WITH STRICT
CODE NINETEEN PROTOCOLS BEING
FOLLOWED. CDCR HAS FURTHER
IMPLEMENTED A WEBSITE AND EMAIL
ADDRESS TO ASSIST IN KEEPING
FAMILY MEMBERS INFORMED OF OUR
EFFORTS. WE CONTINUE WITH
PROACTIVE MEASURES TAKEN TO
CONDUCTING CONTINUOUS
MONITORING SURVEILLANCE AND
TESTING OF BOTH INMATES AND
STAFF. ALL EMPLOYEE HEALTH AND
EMPLOYEE HEALTH UNITS CURRENTLY
BEING STOOD UP TO COMPLETE-
COMPLETE CONTACT TRACING.
RAINING EMPLOYEES A MONITORING
AND TRACKING ALL TESTING FOR
EMPLOYEES TO PREVENT COBA
NINETEEN FROM ENTERING OUR
INSTITUTIONS. STAFF AN INMATE
EFFORTS HAVE NOT GONE UNNOTICED
AND IF PROVEN EFECTIVE AS TWO
OF OUR FEMALE INSTITUTIONS OF
MOVE TO PHASE TWO PROGRAMMING.
PHASE ONE PROGRAMMING AS ARE
MOST RESTRICTIVE WILL FACE TO
EASE THIS PHASE ONE
RESTRICTIONS ALLOWING FOR
MOVEMENT AND PROGRAM AREA
ACCESS WITHIN OUR INSTITUTIONS.
SO WHILE WE HAVE FACED
CHALLENGES WITH KOBE NINETEEN
WOMEN'S PRISONS WE HAVE QUICKLY
ADAPTED AND ARE HEADED IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION I'M HAPPY TO BE
ABLE TO TELL YOU. THE CURRENTLY
WE HAVE ZERO KOBE CASES IN TWO
OF OUR FEMALE INSTITUTIONS. I
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE ABLE TO SHARE THE EFFORTS
OF THE DEPARTMENT STAFF AN
INMATE POPULATION OF THE LAST
SEVEN MONTHS AND WELCOME ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU FOR THAT
MISSI PYLE. NOW WE WILL.
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINE
FOR OUR NEXT PANELIST MISS
PATRICIA RIGHT. MAY HAVE
ACTUALLY NOT JOINED VIA
TELEPHONE BY VIDEO CONFERENCING
I'M SORRY. WELL HERE WE ARE. WE
CAN SEE YOU MISS RIGHT. RIGHT
OKAY. OKAY SO WHAT I CAN THINK
OF IN A GALLON OF SOME FOR MY
RELEASE AND ON. THE MEDICAL
STAFF. ENTIRE MEDICAL STAFF AT
CIW AND C. C. W. F. AND ALL THE
ONES THAT WAS INVOLVED IN MY
RELEASE. THAT WAS INVOLVED IN
SAVING MY LIFE AND MY RELEASE
HIM FOR GIVING ME OUT OF PRISON.
OF. I WAS IN HORRIBLE CONDITION.
BILINGUE BREAST CANCER OVARIAN
CANCER AND BRAIN CANCER WHILE
AN IN QUARANTINE. FOURTEEN DAYS
AFTER DOING CHEMO IT WAS VERY
HARD FOR ME THERE IN PERSON AS
I LEFT SO MANY GOOD FRIENDS
THERE N. O. P. H. U. N. C. C.
P. THERE AND PRESENT. IT WAS
HORRIBLE CONDITIONS CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS ARE PAYING THOUSANDS
AND THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS. FOR
NONSENSE THEY'RE IN PRISON. FOR
SO MANY ON HEARD OF CONDITIONS.
ONE IS NOT EVEN NECESSARY NOW
WHAT DID PAYING FOR MY FIVE
CHILDREN AND- TAKING CARE OF ME
FOR PENNIES A DAY. I'M DYING SO
MUCH BETTER EVEN THOUGH I'M WAS
GIVEN SIX MONTHS OR LESS TO
LIVE. I'M DOING BETTER. I KNOW
I DON'T HAVE LONG TO LIVE. BUT
I'M SURROUNDED WITH LOVE. EVERY
TIME I WENT OUT TO CHEMO. I
WILL NOT TO CHEMO WITH SEVEN
AND A HALF HOURS. OF CHEMO AND
QUARANTINE FOR FOURTEEN DAYS.
AND HORRIBLE CONDITIONS NOTHING
TO CLAIM THE SALE WHICH. IT WAS
HORRIBLE. IT WAS SO HARD FOR ME.
UNBEARABLE CONDITIONS FEEL FREE.
THE DOCTORS WERE SO GOOD TO BE
THE NURSES WAS GOOD TO ME BUT I
HAD HORRIBLE CONDITIONS DELIVER
OAKLAND. YOU ARE JUST DON'T
KNOW WORKERS ELDERLY INMATES
HAVE TO GO THROUGH. I'M SIXTY
NINE YEARS ALL ALL WE HAD TO
GO THROUGH WILL. IMPRESS AND-
I'M LEGALLY BLIND AND HAVE BEEN
LIKE THIS IS THAT WAS SEVENTEEN
YEARS OLD. ELDERLY INMATES AND
PRISON GO TO SO MUCH. IT'S SO
HARD IN PRISON BEYOND ELDERLY
AND SICK. IF GOVERNOR GAVIN
NEWSOM COULD HEAR ME. IT HURTS
SO BAD. PLEASE LISTEN TO ME
GOVERNOR. HELP THE ONES THAT WE
LEFT BEHIND. THEY ARE DYING. I
WAS DYING IN PRISON. YEAH NO
THREAT TO NO ONE THERE. I WAS
LITERALLY DYING EVERY DAY.
ETHNIKI SEVEN I HAVE ALWAYS
KEEN ALL. HIGHLIGHTS THE ANA ON
THAT. HURTING. HURTING EVERY
DAY FOURTEEN DAYS IN QUARANTINE.
I HAD TO TAKE SO WHATEVER
SANITARY NAPKIN AND CLEAN MY
FLOOR. THEY GAVE US NOTHING TO
CLEAN WITH. I WAS IN SO MUCH
PAIN BONES HURTING. R. FOR
EIGHT. BECAUSE I DIDN'T WANT TO
DIE IN PRISON. AB FOR A FROM
OUR FRIENDS AT LEAVE BEHIND
HERE. I JUST FOR A IN AS THE
GOVERNMENT PLEASE LET THEM.
JUST DON'T LET MY FRIENDS DIE
IN PRISON. PLEASE IF YOU LISTEN
TO ME DON'T LET THEM DIE IN
PRISON. IF I COULD DO ANYTHING.
GOOD FRIENDS THERE. AS WELL AS
EIGHTY SEVENTY FIVE EIGHTY
YEARS OLD. IDID TWENTY FOUR
YEARS IN PRISON FOR A CRIME I
DIDN'T COMMIT. WHAT I'M SAY
WITHOUT MONEY JUST SO THEY CAN
CALL ME I CAN'T ZERO EIGHT
ZERO. IT'S EIGHT INCHES CALL ME
JUSTIFIED AT THE OLD. I DON'T
WANT TO HEAR THEM DIANNE IN
PRISON. IT CAN HURT ANYONE IF
THEY COMMITTED THE CRIME DON'T
QUITE SURE OF GOD IS FORGIVING
THE L. GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM
DON'T LET HIM DIE IN PRISON.
HELP THEM PLEASE. THE
CONDITIONS THE HORRIBLE OF
THEIR. I'M SORRY. NO NEED TO
APOLOGIZE MISS RIGHT. HAVE YOU
SAID ALL YOU WANTED TO TELL.
THANK YOU MISS RIGHT FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. I WANT TO REITERATE
THAT THERE IS NO NEED TO
APOLOGIZE. HAVE YOU CONCLUDED
YOUR TESTIMONY. OKAY WELL WE'RE
GOING TO ASK THAT YOU STICK
AROUND IN CASE ANY OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. AND THANK YOU AGAIN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THIS
MODERATE I WOULD NOW LIKE YOU
TO OPEN THE LINE. NO MODERATOR
MY BAD YANNICK CARAWAY WILL
ALSO BE JOINING US. BY THE
VIDEO CONFERENCING MECHANISM
THIS CARE WHERE YOU HEAR. HI
YES I'M HERE GREAT THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ANA CALLAWAY I WAS
CURRENTLY INCARCERATED OR
FORMERLY INCARCERATED AT CC W.
F. I WAS RELEASED IN SEPTEMBER
AFTER SERVING SEVENTEEN HALF
YEARS ON THE SIXTEEN A LIFE
SENTENCE- IN MARCH I WORKED AS
A SUBSTANCE ABUSE COUNSELOR IN
MARCH THEY STOPPED US FROM
WORKING AND- DID INSTITUTIONAL
QUARANTINE- IN JUNE OF THIS
YEAR I WAS FOUND SUITABLE- TO
PAROLE. IN JULY WE STARTED BACK
WORKING FOR APPROXIMATELY SIX
DAYS AFTER THE SIX DAY WE WERE
ALL- SENT TO THAT ISOLATED
CORENTIN ON A YARD BECAUSE WE
HAVE BEEN EXPOSED BY TWO OF OUR
STAFF THAT TESTED POSITIVE-
AFTER THAT I HAVE TESTED
NEGATIVE- SEVERAL DAYS LATER
THERE WERE FIVE STAFF THAT
TESTED POSITIVE. AFTER ELEVEN
DAYS BEING IN THE QUARANTINE
UNITAND TESTING NEGATIVE IDEA
IN A WITH I WAS HOUSE WITH A
ROOMMATE MY ROOMMATE FIRST
TESTED POSITIVE AND THEN TWO
DAYS LATER I TESTED POSITIVE
FROM HER. AFTER BEING IN A
QUARANTINE UNIT- THE QUARANTINE
UNIT WAS ABSOLUTELY DISGUSTING
AND REGARDLESS OF- THE ATTEMPT
FROM CDC ARE TO PROVIDE HAND
SANITIZER SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
THOSE THINGS THAT ARE SUPPOSED
TO BE PREVENTED IT. MATTERS TO
HELP WITH NOT CONTRACT THE
COLGATE- WE WERE IN THAT
ENVIRONMENT THAT WE HAD TO
CLEAN UP OURSELVES IN ORDER TO-
LIVE IN. HUMANE CONDITIONS WE
CLEAN THE CELLS WITH PADS
TAMPONS AND OUR OWN CLEANING
SUPPLIES WHICH WAS LIKE
SHAMPOO- YOU KNOW HAND SOAP
THAT WE BUY OUT OF OUR BOXES-
THEY GAVE US CLEANING SUPPLIES
MAYBE. ONCE A WEEK THAT
EVERYBODY USED IN THE SAME ROOM
ONCE I TESTED POSITIVE I WAS
MOVED TO ANOTHER SIDE OF
QUARANTINE- AND PUT IN A SINGLE
SALE. AND I MY VITALS WERE
TAKEN OPTIONALLY IT WAS NOT
MANDATORY FOR ME TO TAKE. MY
VITALS BY THE NURSES I NEVER
SAW A MEDICAL DOCTOR ARE ONLY
SAW AND ARE IN THE WHOLE TIME I
WAS SICK- THERE WERE TIMES THAT
I COULDN'T EVEN GET OUT OF THE
BED. THERE WAS NO MEDICATION
GIVEN TO ME THERE WAS NO
VITAMINS GIVEN TO ME THERE WAS
NO EXTRA VEGETABLES GIVEN TO ME
THERE WAS NO WATER GIVEN TO ME-
EVERYTHING THAT- ALLOWED ME TO
GET BETTER WITH SOMETHING THAT
I HAD TO USE WITHIN MYSELF- MY
ALL MEANS SO I TAKE VITAMINS
EVERYDAY I HAD TO USE MY OWN
VITAMINS I BOUGHT WATER OFF THE
CANTEEN I HAD TO USE MY OLD
WATER BECAUSE- THE WATER OUT OF
THE SINK I HAD NO WATER
PRESSURE- FOR A COUPLE OF DAYS.
THE STAFF. TREATMENT THE STAFF
WILL COME IN AND SAY THAT THEY
DON'T WANT TO WEAR THEIR MASKS
BECAUSE THEY WANTED TO CATCH
THE VIRUS SO THEY CAN GET TWO
WEEKS PAID LEAVE. YOU KNOW THE
CONTACT WITH MY FAMILY MY
FAMILY WAS CALLING UP TO THE
PRISONS TO CHECK ON ME TO FIND
OUT WHAT WAS GOING ON WITH ME
BECAUSE I ONLY HAD ACCESS TO
EMAIL. AND THEY WERE TELLING MY
PARENTS THAT I WAS GETTING THE
BEST OF HEALTH CARE. WHEN THAT
IS NOT THE TRUTH. AND SO AFTER
BEING TESTED NEGATIVE- AND
BEING RELEASED FROM THE
QUARANTINE- THERE WAS NO
PSYCHIC TO COME AND SEE ME
BECAUSE- HALF THE SYKES DIDN'T
WANT TO COME INTO THE UNITS
THAT WERE QUARANTINE BECAUSE
THEY DON'T WANT EXPOSE
THEMSELVES. TO THE VIRUS. WHEN
IN ALL ACTUALITY THE INMATES
ARE NOT GIVEN IT TO THE STAFF
THE STAFF WERE GIVEN IT TO THE
INMATES. AND SELL. HOW HOW ARE
WE SUPPOSED TO BE ABLE TO
PROTECT OURSELVES. WHEN THERE'S
NOBODY WELL THERE'S NOT MANY
THAT ARE WILLING TO PROTECT US.
AND SO WE HAVE STAFFTHAT ARE
COMING IN THAT RE WILLING TO
CATCH THE VIRUS IN ORDER TO GET
A TWO WEEK PAID LEAVE. ANDTHEN
OUR MEDICAL SYSTEM. IS NOT
ALLOWING US THE PROPER CARE. TO
GET WELL AND- THERE GOES THE
POPULATION. WHEN IT SPREAD LIKE
WILDFIRE- I WAS RELEASED AFTER
THAT. A FROM THE QUARANTINE I
SAW A DOCTOR ARE IN ONCE AND
WHEN I WAS ASKED ABOUT HAVING
ANY SYMPTOMS. BEFORE I WAS
ASKED ABOUT THE SYMPTOMS I WAS
TOLD THAT IF YOU. SAY THAT YOU
HAVE ANY SYMPTOMS ARE GOING TO
IMMEDIATELY SEND YOU BACK TO
QUARANTINE. AND I DON'T WANT TO
GO BACK TO THE QUARANTINE
CONDITIONS SO I SAID I DIDN'T
HAVE ANY SYMPTOMS IN CONTINUE
TO TAKE MY OWN VITAMINS. AND TO
WORK OUT TO- PRODUCE A
HEALTHIER PUT A NEW SYSTEM.
AGAIN LIKE THE HAND SANITIZER
THAT WAS GIVEN IN THE UNITS
WITH WATERY. THE STAFF JUST
WENT ALONG WITH IT BUT WE HEAR
THEM SAYING YOU KNOW I'M GOING
TO GO OUT TO THIS LITTLE OUT
I'M GOING TO GO OUT TO THIS
PARTY I'M GOING TO GO HANG OUT
HERE SO WE KNEW THAT ON IN
THEIR PERSONAL LIVES THEY WERE
NOT TAKING PREVENTATIVE
MEASURES TO NOT CATCH THE
CULPRIT. AND THEN BRING IT BACK
INSIDE TO THE INSTITUTION
PUTTING ALL INMATES AT DANGER
AND SO- YOU KNOW HAVING THE
COLD VIRUS BEING LOCKED IN THAT
CELL BY MY NOT HAVING
ASSISTANCE ONLY SEEN THE NEWS
WHERE PEOPLE ARE DYING IN
SEEING SOME THE STAFF THAT
WORKED AT THE C. W. AT PASSING
AWAY ON THE NEWS- YOU WERE
LIVING IN FEAR CONSTANTLY
WORRYING ABOUT IF YOU ARE GOIN
TO DIE. AND ME BEING SO CLOSE
TO BEING RELEASED HAVING THAT
FEAR BEING SO CLOSE TO BE A
RELEASE- WITH OVERWHELMING
BECAUSE AFTER BEING
INCARCERATED SEVENTEEN AND A
HALF YEARS HAVING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GO HOME AND THEN
CATCHING THE CULPRIT AND NOT BE
BEING GIVEN PROPER MEDICAL
SERVICES. THE FEAR IS I'M NOT
GOING TO MAKE IT OUT I DID I
WOULDN'T MADE IT ALL THIS WAY
TO NOT MAKE IT OUT AND- YOU
KNOW BY THE GRACE OF GOD I HAD
THESE ORGANIZATIONS OUT THERE
ADVOCATING FOR ME BUT IT
SHOULDN'T BE THAT ORGANIZATIONS
ADVOCATING FOR ME IT SHOULD BE
C. D. C. R. THAT IS PROVIDING
FOR ME. WHAT THE TAXPAYERS ARE
PAYING FOR PROPER MEDICAL
ASSISTANCE PROPER FOOD
HEALTHIER LIVING CONDITIONS I
SHOULDN'T BE WORRIED ABOUT IF I
GET A SHOWER IS IF EITHER I'M
GOING TO CATCH THE CULPRIT OR
IF I'M GOING TO CATCH A
BACTERIAL INFECTION BECAUSE OF.
HOW DISGUSTING IT IS. WHEN I
GOT OUT THAT WE HAD THE FIRES
THAT WERE HAPPENING AND SO.
MAYBE IN A HIGH RISK BECAUSE I
HAVE ASTHMA NOT ONLY AM I STILL
HAVING ISSUES WITH MY BREATHING
BECAUSE OF THE COLD AND I'M NOT
HAVING ISSUES BREATHING BECAUSE
OF THE SMOKE. ON TOP OF MY
ASTHMA. I SHOULD HAVE BEEN A
HIGH RISK. RELEASED IT SHOULD
HAVE BEEN A EXPEDITED
IMMEDIATELY ONCE I HAD BEEN.
FOUND SUITABLE AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT THE PROCEDURE IN OTHER
STATES. PEOPLE ARE RELEASED
WITHIN THREE DAYS AFTER BEING
FOUND SUITABLE IN THE STATE WE
HAVE TO WAIT A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
DAYS FOR GOVERNOR'S RELEASE.
WHICH MAKES NO SENSE TO ME
ESPECIALLY WITH THIS CULVERT
TAKING PLACE RIGHT NOW. THOSE
THAT ARE BEING RELEASED ARE
DOES THAT- HAVE SHORT TERMS
WHICH WE UNDERSTAND BUT THERE
ARE ALSO THOSE THAT HAVE LONG
TERMS. THAT HAVE HIGH RISK
MEDICAL CONDITIONS THAT SHOULD
BE CONSIDERED- RIGHT ALONG WITH
THE REST OF POPULATION- ACTS
THAT YOU. IT LOOKS GOOD ON
PAPER WITH WITH THE DOCTORS ARE
SAYING HERE ARE WHAT. CITY R.
CD C. R. STAYING HERE AOUT
WHAT THEY DO TO PREVENT THE
MATTERS OF IN MAYES CATCHING
THE CULPRIT. BUT IN REALITY IN
REALITY IT'S NOT HAPPENING THE
WAY IT LOOKS ON PAPER. AND SO I
BELIEVE THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE
MORE ACTION TAKEN FROM THOSE
THAT ARE IN POSITIONS TO. TO
ACTIVATE- THE PROPER PROCEDURES
THE STAFF SHOULD IT SHOULD BE
PROPERLY TRAINED AND SHOULD BE
HELD TO A HIGHER STANDARD. TO
PROTECT THOSE THAT ARE INSIDE
BECAUSE WE WERE NOT SENTENCED
TO A DEATH SENTENCE WERE
SENTENCED TO DO OUR TIME. TO
REHABILITATE OURSELVES INTENT
THEN TO BE RELEASED INTO
SOCIETY AS PRODUCTIVE CITIZENS
OF SOCIETY. AND IF WE DO NOT
HAVE AN EXAMPLE OF WHAT A
PRODUCTIVE CITIZEN AS SOCIETY
LOOKS LIKE THROUGH THE STAFF
THAT WORK THERE. THEN HOW DO
YOU EXPECT US TO COME OUT AND
TO BE. BETTER PEOPLE. I FEEL AS
THOUGH- WITH THE MEDICAL
TREATMENT- THE MEDICAL STAFF.
NEED TO BE MORE PERSISTENT IN
MAKING SURE THAT THOSE THAT
HAVE. CONTRACTED THE VIRUS FROM
THE STAFF INSIDE THEY GET THE
THINGS THAT THEY NEED BECAUSE
EVERYBODY CANNOT BE PROVIDED
WORK. BY A VENDOR PACKAGE OR
BOX OR- SOMEONE ELSE IN THAT IN
IN THE UNIT HELPING THEM TAKE
CARE OF THEMSELVES THE
INSTITUTION SHOULD BE PROP
PROVIDING THOSE THINGS FOR US.
AND SO I JUST ASK THAT YOU GUYS.
WILL STEP YOUR GAME AND HELPING
THOSE THAT ARE INCARCERATED SO
THAT. WE ARE NOT. SO THAT WE
ARE NOT- STUCK LIVING IN THE
FEAR OF. NOT BEING ABLE TO MAKE
IT OUT AND ALSO GIVEN US THAT
MENTAL HEALTH BECAUSE IT'S NOT
JUST ABOUT OUR PHYSICAL HEALTH
IS ALSO ABOUT OUR MENTAL HEALTH
AND COMING OUT OF THAT YOU'RE
TRAUMATIZED. BECAUSE THEN
YOU'RE OSTRACIZED FROM THE
POPULATION THE POPULATION-
LOOKS AT YOU LIKE YOU HAVE
LEPROSY NOBODY WANTS TO COME
NEXT TO YOU NOBODY WANTS TO
TALK TO YOU BECAUSE THEY'RE
AFRAID ABOUT GETTING SICK AS
WELL AS THE ALL THOSE THINGS
COME INTO PLAY MESSING WITH
SELF ESTEEM AND MESSING WITH-
YOUR MENTAL AND YOU BEING ABLE
TO CONTINUE TO BE PRODUCTIVE IN
COMING OUT OF THE SITUATION-
HEALTHIER THAN YOU DID WHEN YOU
WENT. WENT INTO IT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS CARAWAY I WOULD
NOW LIKE TO OPEN UP THE FLOOR
TO ANY QUESTIONS THAT ARE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MAY HAVE FOR
OUR PANELISTS. SO I'M GOING TO
GO FIRST TO MISS WALDRON DO YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR OUR
PANELISTS. YES THEY HAVE A
COMMON AND THEN A QUESTION THAT
BY MAY MADAM THERE YOU MAY.
OKAY WELL I MEAN WE HEARD THE
MOVING TESTIMONY FROM ABOVE
BOTH MEN RIGHT AND THE STANEK.
AND IT KIND OF. THE BEST PEOPLE
WHO ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF
WHAT'S GOING ON WITHIN OUR
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES ARE
THOSE WHO HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN
THERE AND EXPERIENCE IT
FIRSTHAND. YOU KNOW WHAT WE
HAVE MASS INCARCERATED PEOPLE.
AND HAVE FELT VINDICATED FOR
THAT- WE ARE A SOCIETY THAT HAS
WALKED AWAY EVERY PERSON HAS
THE POTENTIAL AND WE HAVE
FAILED TO RECOGNIZE THE AMENITY%
OF THOSE INSIDE- YOU KNOW WE
HEARD WE JUST HER FIRST HAND
TESTIMONY. THE SICK THE
TRAUMATIZED BOTH SUFFERING.
WITH MENTAL ILLNESS AND SO USE
THE STORE. SO WITHOUT THEIR
THEY NEED SERVICE AND MAIN HELP
EDUCATION AMERICAN LESS THAT
90% OF THOSE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED- COMING HOME AND
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE ACTUALLY. GOING TO BE
REHABILITATED AND RESTORED SO
THAT THEY CAN HAVE IT A
SUCCESSFUL REENTRY AND NOT GO
INTO ANOTHER LIFE OF.
RECIDIVISM FINE. AND IT IS VERY
TO LIGHT SOME OF THE ISSUES OF
HOW WE FOR PEOPLE ON THE INSIDE
WHO ARE THAT ILL OR AND THAT
NEEDS OF SERVICE YOU KNOW. WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
ARE COMING BACK TO THE FULL
POTENTIAL EVERYONE THERE HAS
POTENTIAL AND I THINK THAT
NEEDS TO BE OUR MISSION- YOU
KNOW AND I DO HAVE A QUESTION
FOR MS- EVIL- REGARDING YOU
KNOW SOME OF THE PROTOCOL AND I
KNOW THIS WAS ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT CAME UPON US SUDDENLY AND
SOME OF THESE- THINGS THAT WE
HAVE TO DO WE HAVE TO LEARN
ALONG THE WAY I MEAN WE ALL
REMEMBER THE BEGINNING PEOPLE
SAYS MATHIS AREN'T GOING TO
HELP AND THEN WE HEARD MATH
WILL HAVE OPEN. YOU KNOW SOCIAL
DISTANCING ALWAYS CAN'T BE
FOUGHT THROUGH THE AIR THAN YOU
CAN SO WE LEARNED AS WE WENT
WITH THIS PANDEMIC HOWEVER YOU
KNOW WHAT WHAT'S BEING DONE YOU
KNOWAS FAR AS STAFF AND
PROTECTING STAFF AS WELL I MEAN
I'M GUARD SHARING KEY EIGHT-
YOU KNOW HOW DID THEY HAVE
THEIR OWN OF EVERYTHING SO THEY
DON'T HAVE TO BE SHARING THAT
ARE HAND SANITIZERS READILY
AVAILABLE OR ARE THOSE STILL
CONSIDERED CONTRABAND- AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY- PROTOCOL. DIFFER
FROM PRISON TO PRISON FACILITY
AND EACH WARRANT IS SETTING UP
A LOT OF THE PROTOCOL FOR THEIR
FACILITY AND THAT'S WHAT I'VE
LEARNED IN DISCUSSIONS WITH CDC
ARE OVER THE PAST FEW. MONTHS
MERCEDES THE EACH FACILITY IS
DIFFERENT. AND THEY ALL HAVE A
DIFFERENT LAW OF LAUGHING. AND
THAT'S VERY ONE OF TO ANOTHER
AND THAT'S WHY EACH IN THE BASE
WITH FOR THEIR OWN FACILITY AND
HOW THEY MEET THE STANDARDS. SO
MY QUESTION IS. HOW OVERSIGHT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY HANDLE WHEN
THE FACILITY IS DIFFERENT SO
MUCH AND THEWARDENS HAVE THAT
MUCH LEEWAY. WHAT MEASURES ARE
YOU AND STANDARDS THAT NEED TO
BE MET AND ARE WE GETTING TO
THE POINT WHERE THEY'RE BEING
MET. SO I'LL TRY TO YES LOOKS
LIKE THERE'S QUITE A FEW
QUESTIONS THERE- SO HAND
SANITIZER IS AVAILABLE TO
EVERYONE- STAFF IN MADE AND
ANYONE THAT COMES ON GROUNDS IS
THAT. WE HAVE SITTING ON THE
COUNTER TOPS VERY SIMILAR TO.
IT'S AVAILABLE EVERYWHERE.
THEY'RE ALWAYS BANTER STATE
DIRECTIVE FROM HIGHEST LAST
WEEK SEAVER WHO ARE YOU ARE.
DIRECTIVE OUT ALL THE ENTIRE
INSTITUTION- EVERY INSTITUTIONS
AND EVEN- CECERE FACILITIES
THAT ARE NOT INSTITUTIONS THAT
MASKS WILL BE WORN THERE IS A
VERY FEW TIMES WHEN AMOUNTS CAN
BE TAKEN OFF WITHIN AN
INSTITUTION- BUT THAT DIRECTIVE
IS IN WRITING STAFF FOR BEING
HELD ACCOUNTABLE AND WE'VE
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTED A
MECHANISMS TO TRACK
ACCOUNTABILITY OF- STAFF NOT
FOLLOWING THAT DIRECTIVE WE
TAKE IT AND WEARING MASKS VERY
SERIOUSLY AND THE EXPECTATION
IS THAT EVERYONE WEARS A MASK
REGARDLESS OF CLASSIFICATION-
OR WHERE THEY'RE ASSIGNED
WITHIN AN INSTITUTION. GREAT
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
MISS WALDRON. NO THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER COOPER DO YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS THAT'S WHAT
I THINK THE PANELISTS FOR THEIR
TIME IN THEIR COMMENTS. THANK
YOU I'M- WHY DID HAVE I. WHO
HAVE SO MUCH BUT I'M JUST GONNA
ASK ONE. QUESTION WE'VE HEARD A
LOT- ABOUT THE CLEANLINESS OF
THE FACILITIES AND THE
DORMITORY STYLE FACILITIES FOR
WOMEN. THAT HAVING WOMEN WERE
THEN ASKED TO CLEAN- SPACES
THAT HAD BEEN HOUSE TO BUY
OTHER- INCARCERATED WOMEN WHO
HAD TESTED POSITIVE FOR COKE F
IT- IT DID SEEM CONCERNING TO
HEAR FOLKS SAY THAT THEY HAD
THEY WERE FORCED TO USE THEIR
OWN BARS OF SOAP IN THEIR
SANITARY NAPKINS. TO CLEAN-
THERE SPACES. SO CAN YOU SPEAK
TO. WHAT CDC ARE NEEDS I MEAN
IS THIS AN ISSUE OF
OVERPOPULATION IS THIS ISSUE OF.
NOT HAVING ENOUGH- BUDGETARY
SUPPORT AND RESOURCES IS THIS
AN ISSUE OF. NOT PROFICIENT OR
CLARIFYING PROTOCOLS. SO I
DON'T SEE IS IT BUT AS A
BUSINESS BUDGETARY ISSUE WE
HAVE DEPLOYED AMPLE AMOUNT OF
CLEANING SUPPLIES- YEAH AND
I'VE HEARD FROM MORE THAN ONE
PERSON INDICATING THAT THEY'RE
HAVING TO USE. THEIR OWN
PERSONAL BAR SOHO AND
SANITATION PADS AND- THAT WILL
BE ADDRESSED IMMEDIATELY
FOLLOWING THIS HEARING. AND IT
DEFINITELY LOOKED INTO BECAUSE
WE HAVE PROVIDED A PAPER
TOWELS- CELLBLOCK SIXTY FOUR-
SANTA GUARD WE HAVE PROVIDED
NUMEROUS CLEANING SUPPLIES TO
THE INSTITUTIONS AND IF THERE'S
A NEED. ALL THEY HAVE TO DO IS
ASK AND WE WILL FOLLOW UP I
WILL PERSONALLY FOLLOW UP TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAVE WHAT
THEY NEED- WE HAVE ALSO TAKEN A
STEP FURTHER AND TREATED
TRAINED ALL OF OUR BORDERS. AT
A HEALTH CARE FACILITIES
MAINTENANCE LEVEL OF CLEANING-
SO THAT THEY KNOW HOW TO DO A
TERMINAL TYPE CLEANING AND SO
IF WE NEED TO EXPAND THAT WE
WILL LOOK AT EXPANDING THAT
BECAUSE- WE DON'T WANT THE
SAME. CIRCUMSTANCES THAT HAVE
BEEN SPOKE TO CONTINUE TO
HAPPEN. THANK YOU. SO I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF OUR PANELISTS FOR
SHARING YOUR PERSONAL AND%
PROFESSIONAL STORIES WITH US
AND FOR ELEVATING- MANY OF
THESE ISSUES WE ARE NOW GOING
TO MOVE INTO THE PUBLIC COMMENT
PORTION OF OUR HEARING. AS
STATED AT THE BEGINNING OF OUR
HEARING I WOULD ASK THAT ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HERE IN
THE ROOM PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE ONE PERSON AT A
TIME. AND PLEASE MAINTAIN
SOCIAL DISTANCING AS YOU MOVE
AROUND THE ROOM I WOULD ALSO
ASK THAT THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCH
THE MICROPHONE. I WANT TO
REMIND YOU THAT YOU CAN EXIT
THE HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU ARE
DONE PROVIDING YOUR COMMENTS OR
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT PLEASE BE
SURE TO OBSERVE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING UPON LEAVING THE
CAPITAL. INCLUDING LIMITING
ELEVATOR USED TO ONE PERSON AT
A TIME. I WANT TO REMIND US
THAT WE HAVE A TWO PM HARD STOP
TO ALLOW FOR THE ROOM TO BE
PROPERLY DISINFECTED FOR THE-
NEXT SERIES OF EVENTS HERE.
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN THE ACCESS CODE
IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO
ZERO TWO YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY WEBSITE
AND ON YOUR TELEVISION SCREEN
THE OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL
GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO
BE PLACE IN THE QUEUE TO
PROVIDE YOUR PUBLIC COMMENT. IF
YOU ARE CALLING IN PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE
THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR LIVE
STREAM BROADCAST AND YOUR
DEVICES TO REDUCE THE SOUND
DISTORTION. SO NOW MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU DO HAVE A COMMENT PRESS
ONE THAN THEIR OWN NOW AGAIN
FOR ANY COMMENTS ONE THEN THERE
NOW. WE DO NOT SHOW ANYONE ON
THE LINE AT THIS MOMENT. OKAY
THANK YOU MODERATOR I DON'T
KNOW IF WE HAVE ANY. PUBLIC
COMMENT FROM FOLKS IN THE- OKAY
I SEE PEOPLE ON THE SCREEN. AND
IF THERE'S ANYONE IN THIS
HEARING ROOM THAT HAS A PUBLIC
COMMENT WE INVITE YOU TO THE
MICROPHONE. OKAY I SEE YOU SIR
FROM OUR REMOTE TESTIMONY SPACE.
PLEASE SHARE YOUR PUBLIC
COMMENT. HERE FRANK MAJOR
LIZARD. OF ORANGE COUNTY
CHAPTER OF ALL OF US OR NONE.
AND I WANT TO SPEAK ON THE
SUBJECT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
RIGHT NOW THEREFORE COMMENTS
MAJOR COMMENTS I HAVE SOLVED.
WE GO THROUGH THEM INVESTORS I
CAN YOU CAN HEAR ME OKAY
CORRECT YES WE CAN. THURGOOD
DURING THE NUMBER ONE MISTER
COOPER STATED THAT THERE IS A
50% RECIDIVISM RATE. AS FAR AS
THE PEOPLE BEING RELEASED FROM
PRISON AND THEN RE OFFENDING
AND GOING BACK. I BELIEVE WHAT
HE'S SAYING IS TRUE. HOWEVER HE
LEFT OFF AN IMPORTANT THAT.
LESS THAN 1% OF ALL WOMEN
RELEASED FROM PRISON THE SURVEY
AND END UP GOING BACK TO PRISON
THAT'S THE LOWEST GROUP
COMPARED TO ANY GROUP YOU WANT
TO COMPARE TO RACIAL ETHNIC
GENDER ANYTHING. LESS THAN 1%
OF WOMEN DO ANYTHING THE WOULD
FIND THEMSELVES GOING BACK TO
PRISON KEEP THAT IN MIND.
NUMBER TWO I WAS BUILT THE
WOMEN WHO HAVE SPOKEN TODAY AND
HAS SPOKEN IN THE PAST TAKEN
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THEIR
ACTIONS. IF THEY'VE BEEN IN
PRISON AND NOT CRITICIZING THEM
CLOSER RELATION. THE FACT IS.
THE SAN WOMAN MOST WHOM. NEVER
HAVE BEEN SENT TO PRISON THE
FIRST PLACE THE READER
FACTUALLY IN. OR THE OFFENSE'S
VACANT. NEVER SHOULD RESULT IN
A PRISON TERM ESPECIALLY A LONG
PRISON TERM. AND THEY'LL
THEY'LL NEVER SAY IT. DOES
THAT'S THE KIND OF HIGH
CHARACTER THEY DO HAVE. A LOT
OF THEM ARE INNOCENT SEARCHES
PATRICIA GORDY RIGHT WHO JUST
SPOKE TO YOU JUST JUST NOW.
THERE BEEN PLENTY MORE IS WELL
JUSTICE CENTURY. SO. I JUST
WANTED TO SAY THAT THERE IS
MORE ON THAT ALSO A LITTLE BIT
LATER IF THIS TIME. NUMBER
THREE. PLEASE GET THE GOVERNOR
GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM TO A
POINT PEOPLE WHO ARE FORMERLY
INCARCERATED IN PRISON. ON THE
BOARD OF PAROLES AND HEARINGS.
THERE ARE TWO WOMEN WHO SERVED
DECADES IN PRISON ONLY TO BE
FOUND THEY WERE COMPLETELY
INNOCENT THEY DIDN'T DO
ANYTHING. AND HAVE BEEN
EXONERATED BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. ONE WAS A LAW
STUDENT AT THE TIME SHE WAS
WRONGLY ARRESTED CONVICTED AND
FORCED TO SERVE SEVENTY AND A
HALF YEARS IN PRISON BEFORE
BEING FOUND COMPLETELY INNOCENT
AND THEN EXONERATED STATED
CALIFORNIA. PLEASE PUT ASIDE
POLITICS AND PATRONAGE. AND PAY
OFF- TO POLITICAL COURAGE PUT
THESE WOMEN ON THE BOARD OF
PAROLES AND HE THAT'S A GLOW
KELLUM. AND ROSEANNE PARKER I
REPEAT IT GLORIA KELLUM A WHITE
WOMAN. UNFORTUNATELY RAISES
IMPORTANT AND ROSE AND PARKER A
BLACK WOMAN BOTH WRONGLY
CONVICTED THEY KNOW THE PRISON
SYSTEM AND THEN I'LL THEY
DEFINITELY KNOW PEOPLE WHO CAN
BE PAROLED FROM PRISON AND
SHOULD BOTH OF THEM. ENDED UP
IN PRISON. DIRECTLY OR
INDIRECTLY OR DIRECTLY OR
INDIRECTLY WITH OF A MAN OR MEN.
THEY'RE NOT SURE QUICK TO GRANT
PAROLE TWO MEN IMPRISONED
THEY'LL LOOK AT THEIR CASES BUT
THEY'LL LOOK AT UNFAIRLY. THESE
PEOPLE YOU REALLY NEED ON THE
PAROLE BOARD PLEASE GET THE
GOVERNOR TO DO THAT. NUMBER
FOUR. NOW FOR THE INNOCENT AND
MUCH TOO HARSHLY PUNISH. WOMEN
IN PRISON PLEASE HAVE GOVERNOR
NEWSOM FREE THESE WOMEN
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE OF THE
CORONAVIRUS. SITUATION I HAVE
LISTED A HALF DOZEN PEOPLE
SOMEONE ACTUALLY FRIENDS OF
PUSHES YOUR BODY RIGHT THAT
SHOULD BE FREE. ONE MOMENT.
HERE ARE THEIR NAMES.
ANTOINETTE NANCY. W. SIX SIX
SIX TWO EIGHT. I ACTUALLY
ATTENDED HER TRIAL BY COMPLETE
ACCIDENT. SHE'S BEEN IN PRISON
WELL OVER TWENTY YEARS YOU'VE
BEEN IN PRISON SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY SEVEN COMPLETELY
INNOCENT I'M NOT JUST SAYING IT.
ONE OF THE TRIAL JURORS WHO
HELPED CONVICT TO SAY SHE WAS
INNOCENT. HE LATER FOUND OUT
MISTAKES BOTH THE PROSECUTION
AND DEFENSE NAY AND THIS
MILLIONAIRE BUSINESSMAN WENT
BOTH THE PROSECUTION AND
DEFENSE ATTORNEYS THE STATE
THAT. DONNA KELLEY. NOW SHE'S
GONNA KEEP SAYING THAT YES HE'S
GUILTY ENGINES TAKEN
RESPONSIBILITY FOR CRIMES AND
EVERYTHING OUT THERE AND I WAS
SPECTER WHAT YOU'RE SAYING. BUT
SHE DOES NEED TO BE FREE I
DISAGREE WITH THE AUDIT THAT
GAL SAY OKAY YEAH YOU TO THINGS
YOU KNOW SO YOU DON'T THINK MR
MITCHELL I'M BEEN IN PRISON FOR
OVER TWENTY YEARS MISTER
MITCHELL VERY NICE PERSON SHE
HAS AN ELDERLY MOTHER IS STILL
ALIVE. MICHU SIXTY NINE YEARS
OLD THAT BUILDING- SHE IS
CLEARLY. SHE SHOULD BE FREE.
YOU HEAR ME. W. SEVEN OH EIGHT
OH FOUR. UNFORTUNATELY SHE DID
COMMIT CRIMES AS A RESULT OF
HER ADDICTION. THE CRACK
COCAINE ROCK COCAINE DURING THE
QUOTE CRACK A GOOD EPIDEMIC
UNQUOTE IN SOUTH CENTRAL LOS
ANGELES MISTER MITCHELL I'M
GOING THANK YOU YOU ARE AND
SAID THANK YOU THE PRISON WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE A LOGO OFFER YOU
PRUNE ON TO THE NEXT WITNESS.
BUT I'M HOPING THAT YOU CAN
SHARE THOSE NAMES WITH THE
STAFF THAT ARE THERE BUT I WANT
TO HONOR THE TIME THAT WE HAVE
HERE WITH FOLKS WHO ARE ALSO ON
THE LINE AND ALSO THOSE WHO ARE
IN SOME OF THE OTHER ROOMS BUT
I APPRECIATE YOU FOR SHARING
THOSE NAMES AND I HOPE THAT YOU
WILL GIVE THAT LIST TO THE
STAFF WHO CAN THEN MAKE. SURE
OF AMBER ROSE ROCK. THEY YOU.
HELLO NEXT WITNESS WE SEE YOU
YOU CAN SPEAK FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
FINE DAY TODAY. CHAIRMAN OF
KAMLAGER- I SHOULD SAY HOW
HAPPY I AM TO BE SPEAKING WITH
YOU- I DON'T DOUBT THAT YOU'RE
DECENT HONEST HARD ASSEMBLY
WOMAN AND- I ADMIRE YOUR
COURAGE AND- IN FACING THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE'RE ALL
FACING I KNOW THAT THERE'S
DIFFICULTIES FACING ALL OF US.
IN OUR STATE IN OUR TOWN AND I
KNOW THERE'S DIFFICULT ON ALL
OF US AND I JUST WANTED TO SAY
THAT I DON'T KNOW ANYBODY AND I
DON'T KNOW ANYTHING THAT
ANYBODY ELSE DOESN'T KNOW.
ABOUT WOMEN'S HEALTH AND HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS FOR WOMEN TO-
HAVE THEIR NOURISHMENT AND
NUTRITION THEY NEED I WASJUST
THINKING ABOUT HOW SOMETIMES
WOMEN CAN BE. PREGNANT AND. I
KNOW THAT IT'S SO IMPORTANT FOR
A BABY TO BE ABLE TO. TOUCH THE
SKIN OF HER MOTHER AND TO FEEL
SO CLOSE TO THEIR MOTHER WHEN
THEY'RE BORN. AND I'M JUST A
LITTLE BIT CONCERNED ABOUT SOME
OF THE MEDICATIONS AND VACCINES
THAT SOME WOMEN AND- IN IN THAT
I'M SYSTEM AND THE IMAGE ARMED
INCARCERATED KATE ON. COULD BE
TAKING- I KNOW THAT DOCTORS ARE
PERFECT THE WAY GOD MADE HIM.
I'M JUST LIKE YOU ARE- CHAIR
CHAIRWOMAN ON. KAMLAGER I THINK
THAT WERE OFFERED THE WAY GOD
MADE US. I JUST THINK THAT SOME
OF THESE- MEDICATIONS AND
VACCINES MIGHT HAVE SOMETHING
IN THEM CALLED. BIOTECHNOLOGY
OR MAYBE NANOTECHNOLOGY AND I'M
AND I'M SERVICE ARE NOT TRYING
TO BLAME ANYBODY I KNOW THAT
IT'S DIFFICULT FOR ALL OF US
AND I DON'T THINK THERE'S
ANYBODY. THAT I KNOW OF TO
BLAME I THINK WE'RE ALL
PERFECTLY GOT MASON I THINK
IT'S A DIFFICULT SITUATION FOR
ALL OF US. I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT ON SOME OF THIS STUFF CAN
HAVE SOMETHING SAW NANA RADIOS
AND HAVE PEOPLE HEARING THINGS
AND HAVE PEOPLE TALKING TO HIM
AND- I'M JUST AFRAID THAT MIGHT
GET TO CHILDREN AND I'M
PROBABLY JUST A FOOL. BUT I'VE
BEEN THROUGH SOME THINGS HAVE
BEEN REALLY DIFFICULT AND IT
WOULD BREAK MY HEART TO KNOW
THAT COULD HAPPEN TO ANYONE AT
ALL. ESPECIALLY A CHILD AND I
MAY JUST BE A FULL AND I
PROBABLY AM BUT I'M TRYING TO
DO THE RIGHT THING. AND I HOPE
THAT YOU KNOW CHAIRMAN I'M
KAMLAGER THAT YOU'RE PERFECT
THE WAY GOD MADE YOU AND I
THINK. THAT EVERYONE IN OUR IN
OUR COUNTRY AND OUR STATUS PER
THE WAY GOD MADE US AND
SPECIALLY MAYBE EVEN US
ESPECIALLY DOCTORS GOT LESSEN
THE BRING BABIES INTO THE
WORLD. I JUST THINK WE NEED TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT SOME
OF THE STAFF AND SO THAT THE
PUBLIC CAN BE AWARE OF THE
POSSIBILITIES OF SOMETHING THAT
MIGHT BE GOING ON. AND I MIGHT
JUST BE A FULL I SAY AGAIN I
PROBABLY AM. BUT I'M TRYING TO
DO THE RIGHT THING AND I AND I
HOPE YOU KNOW YOU'RE PERFECTLY
GOT MAJOR I HOPE THAT ALL THE
WOMEN IN THE IN THE AND ACROSS
RATE SYSTEM GOD BLESS AND I
HOPE THEY THAT THEY'RE ALL
RIGHT I HOPE THEY KNOW THEY'RE
GONNA THINK I MA'AM AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH WISH YOU WELL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU. MODERATOR CAN YOU OPEN THE
LONG. FOR THE- WITNESS AND THEN.
GO TO THE- A MAN STANDING HERE.
MODERATOR CAN YOU OPEN THE LINE
FOR THE NEXT WITNESS ON THE
PHONE. MODERATOR ARE YOU THERE.
YES CAN YOU HEAR ME YES HELLO
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU HI. SORRY
ARE YOU WANTING. ONE FREDDIE
FRANCIS YEAH I'M READY. FREDDIE
WE CAN HEAR YOU PLEASE SHARE
YOUR PUBLIC COMMENT OKAY. GREAT
THANK YOU HI MY NAME IS BETTY
BRANT THAT THEY WORK AT THE
TRANSGENDER ADVOCACY GROUP-
REGARDLESS OF DOCTOR KLEIN IN
THE NETBOOK THE ENTITY CARE ACT
POLICIES ON PAPER IF YOU ARE
STAFF LIKE DO NOT FOLLOW THEY
MEASURES DVRS BECAUSE ACTUALLY.
OF DIFFERENT YOU MEASURE ARE
AND- REALLY THINK POPULATION
ONLY TO SAVE LIVESACCORDING TO
THE MET TEAM. THE TWENTY FOUR I
WORK WITH THAT BUT MEN AND
WOMEN PATELLA ALREADY TARGETED
BY HARASSMENT AND IN ADDITION
EXPERIENCING THE BARRIERS TO
HELP. I KNOW MOST PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BEEN SEXUALLY ASSAULTED BY
TDC ARE DOCTORS AND BY. ABUSING
DISREGARD FOR HEALTHY TEETH THE
PATTERN NOT AND- OUR PEOPLE ARE
TO READ A BILL AND THE SECOND.
I URGE PRESIDENT TO TAKE
SERIOUSLY THE MEDIC TO AND CALL
PERFECT PERCENT RATE OF PRINT
COPY. AT THE MEETING START A
HIGH THAT HE BE A PERPETUATE
THANKS FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
FREDDIE. MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE LINE FOR THE NEXT WITNESS.
SURE AND IF YOU THAT PRESS ONE
THEN OWN. NO LOOKS LIKE WE DO
HAVE A FEELING LIKE YOU'LL BE
JUST A MOMENT OKAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU MODERATOR. HAVE A
MINDER ONE THEN FERAL HERE TO
TESTIFY. SB JUST A MOMENT OKAY.
WELL NEXT MOVES TO LINE THIRTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN CLEAR
ROGER CLEMENS. WONDERFUL THANK
YOU MY NAME'S COURTNEY HANSON-
I ORGANIZED WITH. THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION. FOR
UNITED KERR RESPONSIBLE BUDGET
AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HOLDING THIS MEETING TODAY-
THANK YOU SO MUCH THE FORMERLY
INCARCERATED PEOPLE. THAT SPOKE
AND SHARED THEIR EXPERTISE AND
EXPERIENCE AND I JUST WANT TO
ASK THE QUESTION OF WHEN WE'RE
LISTENING TO THIS DIALOGUE BACK
AND FORTH AND THE COMPARISONS
OF THE TROOPS WHO HAVE A VESTED
INTEREST. IN LINE. WHEN PEOPLE
TALK ABOUT BECAUSE CONDITION.
BEING THAT YOU'RE NOT BEING A
DUNGEON. UNLIKE HOW DO YOU
THINK ONE REACHES A POINT
MENTALLY WHAT ARE ONLY WAY OUT
OF IT SITUATION IS THE LIGHTING
FELL ON FIRE AND IF THE SAME
PEOPLE FIGHTING COLORING BOOK
PAGES UNDER YOUR CELL ARE THE
SAME PEOPLE JOKING ABOUT HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO INFECT YOU
WITH THE VIRUS AND GET A TIME
OFF. YOU THINK GENUINE CARE IS
ACTUALLY POSSIBLE IN THIS
INSTITUTION IT'S NOT THE ONLY
WAY TO SAVE LIVES ACTUALLY THE
CAR THREE AND ACTUALLY ISSUE
MASS MERCHANTS THE RELEASE SAYS
LIFESAVING RELEASES AND THE
WOMEN'S PROGRAM WHO OFTEN
FORGOTTEN ARE THE LOGICAL.
PLACE TO START. AT THE PROBABLY
KNOW WOULD BE A HUGE
SIGNIFICANT. ROLE IN AROUND
QUITE MANY OUT THERE. AND JUST
THE KLEIN MADE VERY. POINT
SAYING THAT QUOTE YOU. OF WHITE
THAN OTHER OLD PRESENT. WHO
HAVE COMMITTED IF IN THE- THIRD
LENGTHY CRAVEN TERMS IF. COULD
GIVEN THEIR LOW. YOU TO
VIOLENCE AND HIGHWAY GIVEN AND
THE AREA. ILLNESS. AND IT HAD
IT HAD BEEN QUITE AND NOT THE
WAY. SECTION THERE WOULD BEEN
WHAT THE SAME. BECAUSE OF THE
AND ISSUES WITH. SETTINGS ARE
CRAP PRISON. THANK YOU FOR
HOLDING THE HEARING. WE HOLD
THE NEW YORK. FOR THE OUTRIGHT
LIES. INCREASE YOUR EVERYTHING
YOUR POWER TO ABBOTT FOR LIFE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU SO
MUCH NOW LIKE TO GO TO THE
PUBLIC COMMENT HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. GOOD AFTERNOON-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COME WATER DOWN
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR HOLDING
THIS COMMITTEE. MEETING TODAY-
IT HAS BEEN VERY EMOTIONAL
TESTIMONY THAT I THINK WE CAN
ALL AGREE THAT WE HAVE HEARD-
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE NOTE OF IT IS THAT
WE HAVE THESE WOMEN'S
FACILITIES THAT ARE FULL OF
AGING AND ELDERLY WOMEN BUT
ALSO WE HAVE A LOT OF WOMEN WHO
HAVE BEEN WRONGFULLY CONVICTED.
WE HAVE WOMEN WHO HAVE BEEN
VICTIMS OF DIFFERENT FORMS OF
VIOLENCE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WHO
ARE NOW FINDING THEMSELVES
INCARCERATED FOR EITHER BEING
DIRECTLY INVOLVED WHEN A CRIME
RELATED TO THEIR ABUSER HAVING
KILLED THEIR ABUSER OR SOME
FORM OFRETRIBUTIVE TYPE
JUSTICE THAT THEY HAD TO
EXERCISE- I THINK THAT WE ARE
DOING A DISSERVICE. TO THESE
WOMEN BY CONTINUING TO KEEP
THEM INCARCERATED- IT WAS.
TRAUMATIC JUST HEARING I AM NOT
FORMALLY INCARCERATED BUT IS
DRAMATIC HEARING THE TESTIMONY
OF THESE WOMEN'S- AS I LOOKED
AT MISS PRICE- SHE REMINDED ME
SO MUCH OF MY OWN GRANDMOTHER-
AND THIS IS JUST THIS IS
INHUMANE THIS IS CRUEL FOR
WOMEN TO- HAVE TO USE THEIR
SANITARY NAPKINS IN ORDER TO
CLEAN. THE ROOMS THAT THEY'RE
IN IS JUST IT'S ABSOLUTELY
APPALLING AND SO I TOO AM HERE
TO ASK GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM-
AS WE ARE TALKING ABOUT DOING
MASS RELEASES AT SAN QUENTIN-
OFTEN TIMES WHEN WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM-
IT IS SOLELY FOCUSED ON THE
MALE POPULATION AND THE WOMEN'S
POPULATIONS HAVE BEEN
FORGOTTEN. SO I AM ASKING THAT
THE GOVERNOR BEGAN TO LOOK AT
RELEASING THESE WOMEN AS WELL A
WOMAN IN HER SIXTY SEVENTY
EIGHTY YEARS OLD WAS SUFFERING
FROM DEBILITATING HEALTH CARE
CHRONIC ISSUES IS NO LONGER A
THREAT. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THAT I TOO SO MY GRANDMOTHER
AND MY MOTHER IN THE TESTIMONY
OF MISS RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO
GO BACK TO THE PHONE NOW MY-
PLEASE A THE LINE FOR THE NEXT
WITNESS METAL CAROLINE THIRTY
TWO CLEVELAND HAD. HI THANK YOU
ALL FOR SENDING THE TIME ON
THIS HELLO MY NAME IS DIANA
BLOCK- I'M WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR WOMEN PRISONERS I
SO APPRECIATE THE TESTIMONY
FROM ALL THE UP FORMERLY
INCARCERATED WOMEN IN
PARTICULAR AND PUT THE TIME
THAT BEING SPENT- HEARING IT I
THINK THE CRITICAL THING I MEAN
MANY OF THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
COMMENTED HAVE MADE THE POINT
THAT ABOUT THE NEED FOR
RELEASES THAT IS ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL. THE AT THE OTHER
PIECE THAT I REALLY WANT TO
STRESS IS THAT WITHOUT SOME
ACCESS OR PEOPLE INSIDE PRISON
FOR PEOPLE TO DIRECTLY HEAR
FROM THEM THEN YOU WILL ONLY
GET THE OFFICIAL STORY THE CDC
ARE STORY WHICH IS NOT. WHAT IS
REALLY HAPPENING WE INCREASE
THE W. P. HAVE BEEN HEARING
FROM THE BEGINNING OF THE
PANDEMIC THE KIND OF CONDITIONS
THAT- PATRICIA RIGHT YANNICK
CARAWAY OTHERS HAVE TESTIFIED
ABOUT. DONE UP BUT NO. ONE IS
LISTENING. NOTHING HAS CHANGED
IT EASY SOMEONE TO SAY THAT
WILL ALL WORK O GO IN THE MALL
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE ALL THESE
CHANGES. BUT WHERE IS THE OLD
WHO IS GOING TO SEE WHETHER
THOSE CHANGES ARE ACTUALLY
BEING MADE. I URGE YOU PLEASE
MADAM CHAIR. FIGURE OUT HOW TO
ACTUALLY FOLLOW UP ON
EVERYTHING YOU'VE HEARD TODAY
AND VERIFY THAT THE THINGS THAT
ARE BEING FED. BY CDC R.
OFFICIALS ARE ACTUALLY TRUE
BECAUSE IF YOU GO AND VERIFY
YOU'LL SEE THAT IT'S NOT AND
THEN IN FACT THE PARABLE.
CONDITIONS OF QUARANTINE OF
HAVING TO USE A SANITARY PAD
FOR CLEANING IS WHAT THE NORM
HAS BEEN. SO THAT IS THAT IS
REALLY WHAT I HOPE THAT CAN BE
TAKEN AWAY FROM THIS. BESIDES
ALL THE INCREDIBLE POINTS AND
THEN MADE BY INDIVIDUALS IN THE
NEED FOR VERIFICATION. BY AN
OUTSIDE BODY BESIDES CDC ARE
BECAUSE- AS PEOPLE HAVE SAID T.
V. C. R. CANNOT POLICE ITSELF
IT CANNOT BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
IT DOESN'T SEEM TO BE ABLE TO
BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE AND WE NEED
A DIFFERENT METHOD. IN ORDER TO
REALLY MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
ARE LIVING UNDER DIFFERENT
CONDITIONS AND THAT MOST
IMPORTANTLY THE PEOPLE WHO NEED
TO BE RELEASED. GET RELIEF SOON
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE NEXT
WITNESS ON THE LINE AND I'M
GOING TO ASK THAT ARE
WITNESSES- EXERCISE SOME
BREVITY SO THAT WE CAN MAINTAIN
OUR OUR STOP TIME. MODERATOR.
OPEN THE LINE FOR THE NEXT
WITNESS. TERREL NEXTCODE
ALIGNED TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE
GLAD. LINE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MAXIMO CAROLINE
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SO WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE THANK
YOU AT THE MOMENT. OKAY WE I'D
HEARD YOU HAD SIX ON THE LINE
IS THAT TRUE. THANK YOU AT THE
MOMENT YES IN THE QUEUE ANY
OTHERS IN THE QUEUE. THERE
THERE IS NO MORE AND LIKE YOU
AT THE MOMENT OKAY GREAT THANK
YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES WANTING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY. THROUGH
REMOTE. SEEING NINE DO WE HAVE
ANY MORE IN THIS HEARING ROOM
THAT WOULD WISH TO PROVIDE A
PUBLIC TESTIMONY. OKAY I AM
GOING TO HOPE THAT YOU TOO WILL
ALSO. EXERCISE SOME BREVITY AS
I MENTIONED EARLIER WE HAVE A
TWO PM. STOP ON THIS HEARING
ROOM THANK YOU OKAY SO. I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT I CAN BE
HEARD YOU CAN WE CAN HEAR YOU
BUT I CAN BE SEEN AND YOU SAID
TWO PM DOES THAT GIVE ME THE
FOUR MINUTES RIGHT CERTAINLY
USE IT. WELL I'D LIKE TO
PROVIDE PREP CLOSING REMARKS IF
YOU DON'T MIND ALREADY- I
ACTUALLY JUST WANT TO OFFER A
LITTLE BIT OF- SOMETHING FROM.
ST FRANCIS OF ASSISI. GRANT
THAT I MAY NOT SO MUCH SEEK TO
BE CONSOLEDAS TO CONSOLE. TO
BE UNDERSTOOD AS TO UNDERSTAND.
TO BE LOVED AS TO LOVE FOR IT
IS IN THE GIVING THAT WE
RECEIVE. AND ANOTHER LITTLE BIT
OF A POEM THAT MATTERS TO ME.
LIFE IS MOSTLY FROTH AND BUBBLE
TWO THINGS STAND LIKE STONE.
KINDNESS IN ANOTHER'S TROUBLE
COURAGE IN YOUR OWN AND I'LL
GIVE THAT CREDIT TO ADAM
LINDSAY GORDON. EIGHTEEN THIRTY
THREE TO EIGHTEEN SEVENTY. AND
IF I DO HAVE ANOTHER MOMENT.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE ME AWHILE TO
PROCESS THIS HEARING THIS IS
THIS IS A REALLY BIG TOPIC AND
I'M NOT AT ALL- SAYING WHAT I
ANTICIPATED I'D BE SAYING BUT
IN THE SPIRIT OF WHAT THAT
OTHER COMMENTER SAID- THAT WAS
OUTSIDE AT ONE OF THOSE
STATIONS. SOMETHING THAT HAD
BEEN IN MY MIND WHEN I WAS
RUSHING OVER HERE WAS THIS
NOTION OF PREGNANT WOMEN- I
HAVE FOUR CHILDREN- I'VE BEEN
PREGNANT- NINE TIMES A LOT OF
PREGNANCY LOSS. AND THE THOUGHT
OF THESE WOMEN BEING PREGNANT
AND BEING SUBJECTED TO THESE
CONDITIONS THAT YOU KNOW THESE
ACT EXPERT WITH WITNESSES HAVE.
DESCRIBED IT'S OF DEEP CONCERN
TO ME. AND MAYBE FOR DIFFERENT
REASONS THAN THE- GENTLEMAN
THAT GAVE WITNESS EARLIER WAS
SPEAKING OF BUT BUT THE SAME
TOPIC OF THE BABIES AND- THE
VACCINES. AND THESE KINDS OF
THINGS. SO I JUST WANTED TO
READ SOMETHING THAT- ALSO
MATTERS TO ME. CALLED THE.
NASCO. UNIVERSAL DECLARATION ON
BIOETHICS AND HUMAN RIGHTS
WHICH WAS ADOPTED IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FIVE ON BEHALF OF
A GLOBAL CONSENSUS AND IT
INVOLVED ONE HUNDRED AND NINETY
THREE COUNTRIES INCLUDING THE
UNITED STATES. ARTICLE SIX ONE
TALKS ABOUT CONSENT. AND IT
DECLARES THAT ANY PREVENTATIVE
DIAGNOSTIC AND THERAPEUTIC
MEDICAL INTERVENTION IS ONLY TO
BE CARRIED OUT WITH THE PRIOR
FREE AND INFORMED CONSENT OF
THE PERSON CONCERNED BASED ON
ADEQUATE INFORMATION. THE
CONSENT SHOULD WHERE
APPROPRIATE BE EXPRESS AND MAY
BE WITHDRAWN BY THE PERSON
CONCERNED AT ANY TIME AND FOR
ANY REASON WITHOUT
DISADVANTAGED OR PREJUDICE AND
I WOULD HOPE THAT THAT WOULD BE
SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE
PROTECTING. INCARCERATED WOMEN.
HE KILLED EARLY PREGNANT WOMEN
WHO ARE INCARCERATED BECAUSE-
THERE IS JUST SIMPLY NO MORE
IMPORTANT. HUMAN RIGHTS THEN
THE RIGHT TO CONTROL. WHAT IS
INJECTED INTO OUR BODIES A WHAT
IS PUT IN OUR BODIES- IN MY
POINT OF VIEW AND AGAIN SO MUCH
FOR THAT IN THE INTEREST OF
BREVITY I HAVE THREE MORE
LITTLE LINES AND ALL BE DONE SO
IT'S TWO O'CLOCK RIGHT NOW OKAY
JUST IT'S LIKE THIRTY SECONDS
OKAY I HAVE MY WATCH THE AVIS
BROTHERS IT'S FROM A SONG
CALLED FEBRUARY SEVEN. I WENT
ON THE SEARCH FOR SOMETHING
REAL TRADED WHAT I KNOW FOR HOW
I FEEL. BUT THE CEILING AND THE
WALLS COLLAPSED UPON THE
DARKNESS I WAS TRAPPED AND AS
THE LAST OF BREATH WAS DRAWN
FROM ME. THE LIGHT BROKE IN AND
BROUGHT ME TO MY FEET. THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU SO WITH
THAT I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE
FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION AND FOR
YOUR WILLINGNESS TO LISTEN. I
TOOK A NUMBER OF NOTES DURING
THE COURSE OF THIS HEARING I
WANNA RAISE UP THE NAME MADONNA
WATSON WHO DIED WHILE
INCARCERATED. I WANT TO.
REITERATE THE CHALLENGES WE'VE
HEARD AROUND SAFETY PROTOCOLS
BOTH FOR THOSE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED IN LIVING BEHIND
BARS AND THOSE WHO ARE ACTUALLY
WORKING IN THE SYSTEMS. I WAS
JUST REFLECTING DURING THIS
HEARING ABOUT JUSTIN TURNER WHO
WAS PART OF A TEAM THAT WON THE
WORLD SERIES THIS WAS A PERSON
WHO TESTED POSITIVE FOR COVE IT
WAS TAKEN OFF THE FIELD WITH
ALL KINDS OF TELEVISION CAMERAS
WATCHING HIM AND HE STILL
SOMEHOW ENDED UP BACK ON THE
FIELD WITHOUT WEARING A MASK SO
IF THAT CAN HAPPEN WITH SOMEONE
WITH. ALL KINDS OF TELEVISION
CAMERAS ON HIM WHAT'S GOING ON
IN SPACES WHERE WE DON'T HAVE
THAT KIND OF VISIBILITY. MENTAL
HEALTH HAS SOMETHING THAT HAS
CONTINUED TO COME UP- HOW WE
DEAL WITH OUR PRISON REDUCTION.
AND A PLEA TO MR GOVERNOR ON
BEHALF OF MISS RIGHT AND OTHERS
TO REALLY. EXAMINE THE LIST OF
ELIGIBLE WOMEN WHO SHOULD NOT
BE DYING OR AGING BEHIND BARS.
AND WE WILL BE DOING A FOLLOW
UP ON SOME THINGS THAT I HEARD
THAT I WOULD BE HOPING FOR MORE
CLARITY ON I WROTE DOWN. GPS
MONITORING AND TRACKING BECAUSE
I FELT LIKE I HEARD SOME
STATEMENTS FROM. OUR STE IT WAS
STAFF AT CDC ARE ABOUT HOW
WE'RE SORT OF MONITORING- HOW
FOLKS ARE MOVING- AND SO WE
WOULD LOVE TO FOLLOW UP WITH
YOU ON THAT- WE DON'T WANT OUR
PRISONS TO BECOME FACTORIES OF
DESPAIR. OR DEATH. AND IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT WE FIND WAYS TO
DO CAR STRAIGHT WOMEN AND
SUPPORT THE HAGUE DIGNITY AND
HEALTH OF THOSE WHO ARE BEHIND
BARS AND THOSE WHO ARE WORKING
IN THOSE SYSTEMS. I SPEAK FOR
ALL OF US WHEN I SAY THAT WE
ARE HUMBLED AND WE ARE GRATEFUL
TO ALL OF THOSE WHO BRAVE TODAY
TO SHARE THEIR TESTIMONY AND
THEIR WORK I DO APPRECIATE YOU
AND HOE YOU CONSIDER ME AS A
PARTNER. WITH THAT WE WILL
OFFICIALLY CONCLUDE THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON HEARING ON
INCARCERATED